let's see can you hear me
yeah I got you can you hear me yeah
perfect all right
I think we are alive Jason you got me
there I can hear you
let's see perfect it is time to have
some fun bang bang bang what's up dude
I'm just ready to drink I'm really
impressed with the last 20 minutes
you guys are like your own IT team over
in the pop Liana residents joke locust
is all over it
let me just tweet this out real quick we
are live streaming for a few hours to
celebrate the third Bitcoin having come
join me Jason and what you want to do
what sponsors real quick yeah hit it
what what a combo block fire first
well that's Oh get in here yeah I
treated out a link earlier to block Phi
they've got a pretty cool promotion but
you know again if you're looking to to
get your your money making some money
your crypto making some money I think
it's a great opportunity to send Bitcoin
by a stable coin and collect interest on
that they also have some really cool
lending features and they're generally a
good group of people historically have
been super frustrated with you know
customer service with alternatives and
it's really good to have such an
interactive thoughtful team you can get
8.6% APY on your stable tokens and gosh
i think they're paying 5% plus on
Bitcoin right now yeah I think is really
interesting 5 or 6% and then also with a
8.6 percent on
on the Fiesta ST that's right yeah it's
it's really I think it's a great deal
for sure and then the other sponsor is
Gemini they offer industry-leading suite
of crypto native products advanced
trading tools for individuals and
institutions they enable you to buy sell
and store cryptocurrency with
world-class security compliance and
customer experience
there are licensed digital asset
exchange and qualified custodian New
York trust company regulated by the New
York State Department of Financial
Services it's about giving you greater
choice independence and opportunity they
are here to serve your journey I think
it's cool that both Gemini and block Phi
are there focus on the most important
thing which is trust through security
right yeah you know I've kind of taken a
multi a multi company approach to this
whole like how do you deal in
cryptocurrency and it's been difficult
to just use one so using like Gemini
Gemini has some features that block Phi
doesn't have if you want to put limit
orders in put stop losses in you know
stack orders in Gemini's really really
cool and I use them for an on and off
ramp
personally and then block Phi has these
interest-bearing options different suite
of crypto assets that you can play
around with and if you don't want to
sell your crypto and need a loan they
can do that too so you know there's
there's an interesting approach to use
both of these companies yeah all right
we are what probably hour and a half two
hours away from the having no man I
think we're nine blocks away and really
now about an hour away that seems to be
moving really quick so hey I'm sorry to
all those who are trying to to link up
with us that were kind of panicking that
we were gonna miss the having but I
think we're here so we are definitely
here maybe talk a little bit for those
that don't know let's start with just
your background and stuff so that then
people you go first my whole intention
today was to interview you like I I
don't think there's been not a hold on a
second I don't think there's actually
been an interview that that
kind of figured out who you were what
you've done so I'd rather I'd rather
kind of hear a little bit about you your
background your family let's get a
little personal today we are not going
now how do we get the name Anthony pop
Leone oh people don't know who you are
what tell them a little bit by your
background first ah so you know my name
is Jason Williams and one of the three
general partners over at Morgan Creek
digital before that I practiced medicine
for for about 20 years actually as a
physician assistant for those that don't
know what that is it was born out of
kind of Naval corpsman coming back from
Vietnam back in the 70s they couldn't
transition into private practice so Duke
University started a program for
transitioning these ex-military guys
into the civilian world so they're
really capable dependent practitioners
as a part of a multidisciplinary
healthcare team when I was at Methodist
they started a PA program I was accepted
finished the program went off to Yale
and while I was a Yale came up with the
idea for a company called fast med which
is just urging cares but this is back in
2001 I ended up dropping out of my my
residency and building that company over
a 14-year period into the nation's
second largest urgent care and primary
care practice we were doing like 1.5
million patient visits a year had 1400
employees it was really my whole adult
life's work up until that point and I
sold the company in 2015 for about half
a billion dollars so it was
transformational in terms of my own kind
of progression from a bootstrapping
entrepreneur to someone working in a
private equity venture backed situation
reporting to a board and then having a
big exit so and that's when I met you
yeah I feel like in that process all
right just send an email I think
everyone on the list hopefully they all
got it well we'll see here but as part
of that process like what were some of
the things that you learned that you
think apply to Bitcoin like I know we've
talked a bunch about just managing
people and a centralized corporation how
hard that is and hiring and firing and
all this
and then you've got this thing Bitcoin
that's completely decentralized takes
none of that into account but still has
grown into 170 billion dollar asset but
how do you think about the difference
there yeah it's it's fun to explore how
Bitcoin if you if you look at it as a
business it's like the perfect business
it doesn't really have any employees it
grows with this virality and it has all
of these business type segments or parts
to it like it has this marketing team
that it doesn't pay and it's got this
like this this kind of monetary policy
that doesn't have a CFO or some type of
a board engaging it it's all kind of run
by an algorithm and and this thing is
just growing like crazy on top of that
you've got all these businesses that are
trying to build on top of blockchains
and and develop innovation over these
simple concepts of you know a triple
entry ledger accounting system smart
contracts etc and and here we are with
this this kind of next-level
internet where you're going to be able
to transact you know in a very
interesting way yeah it's um it's gonna
be I think interesting to see if more
companies start to do this in the future
right in terms of are there ways to
build decent-sized organizations are
there ways to have anonymous or
pseudonymous founders it just feels like
all of that stuff is uh is now coming to
the forefront Bitcoin may be the only
one to ever do it or maybe other people
will be able to I don't know there's
some concepts that have come out that
I've just not agreed with and they've
been pretty popular I mean the the
Airbnb marketing stuff
like I forget what was it book
blitzscaling yeah why just LinkedIn oh
yeah yeah
linked uh I just hated the concept and I
I hope that if anyone's listening maybe
you could you know challenge this but
you know
literally scaling at all costs not
following up with customers not
listening to customers because the the
viral expedited growth process leaving
leaving customers in a ditch not
answering any customer service like
complaints or or issues just because
growth at all costs is is the the new
the new strategy I just hate it yeah and
I know that that's not been the issue
with Airbnb right now but I wondered if
you know if without this economic kind
of shut down and the pandemic what a
problem showed itself with that strategy
yeah I mean look at the end of the day
we don't know I think is the short
answer but at the same time it's a
business that focuses on scale right and
then kind of says we'll clean it up
later like coin I mean look coin based
did it right they very much at one point
they had hundreds of thousands of a
customer tickets I think right over here
yeah and coin based breaks it is true I
mean they go down whenever there's big
spikes yeah III have an over and under
weather coinbase coinbase breaks during
the having like at the having yeah I
mean oh it's just wild it reminds me of
like that early days like 2015-2016
anytime you wanted to trade if there was
any real volume the exchanges would be
down yeah they just can't handle it
technically I'm just surprised at this
stage this many years down the road that
these that coinbase is still having this
issue yeah well I think part of it too
at home before I forget leave comments
and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can
also I was told like the video smash the
like button so that more people on
YouTube get this and then subscribe to
the channel I'm supposed to say that
periodically along with talking about
our sponsors so don't forget to do that
stuff but I do wonder how much of
this stuff is technological solutions
meaning like we actually don't have the
technology in place versus just it takes
time to build things that could handle
that type of volume right like we've
seen it outside of crypto as well like
Robin Hood went down on a day where
there's tons of volume in the stock
market and it's just you know how much
is time dependent right in terms of
being able to actually handle that type
of volume maybe my expectations are
unrealistic I mean going back to when I
tried to buy Facebook during their IPO I
mean it broke and I got caught on the
wrong side of the New York Stock
Exchange going down Nasdaq or New York
Stock Exchange and when it turned back
on it like filled an order that totally
sucked for me and I was part of a class
action lawsuit against Facebook and got
paid like two dollars an 11 cents for
four literally dude seriously if he if I
would have got the trade I wanted who
have been worth millions of dollars it's
just totally sucked but this stuff
happens all the time of course all right
I'm looking at comments here of
questions let me address a couple of
things real quick one polina is any
other room she'll come over here and a
little bit come say hey so everyone
leave her alone - not eating pizza at
the moment I have a pepperoni and cheese
and I've got some chicken nuggets but a
pizza may or may not be on the way and I
don't know what Jason is eating or
drinking he'll tell us here yeah he's
got Miller Lite yeah that's it and and
what's going on with the facial hair
there's questions about this ridiculous
foo Manchu that you've got going on no I
mean I saw Mike Novogratz on TV I mean
his mustache was glorious I mean he just
looked like a absolute savage to me a
leader of men and I was like I can grow
a mustache and so I thought I would do
this for this this event and I am rockin
the foo Manchu but unfortunately I
a pretty important call before this
video call so everyone got to see this
ridiculous facial hair on that call
I'm sure Marquess coves gonna be happy
about that polina just poked her head
out and just started laughing because
she heard me talking about your ear
facial hair says yeah you know I've seen
a photo of you with something like this
I at one point grew a massive beard
yeah and I cut it off in stages I think
I went I went it was a goatee but really
long then I cut it into the Foo Manchu
and then I went mustache but the
mustache I had it so that it would curl
at the end right the classic that lasted
for about 24 hours and I realized I had
to go to work the next day so I think I
think anyone that grows a pretty good
beard and decides to cut it goes through
that whole evolution you know yeah 70s
porn stache and chew giant sideburns you
know it's just it's how you take it down
well speaking of taking down are you
watching the Bitcoin price yeah what's
going on I'm not looking at it at the
moment
it's it's it looks like it's turned
around so I'm looking at the 4-hour
chart 82nd well the 4-hour chart today
had a high of 91 91 86 but now it's at
85 64 so this is interesting it's pretty
down so I wonder it's down about three
point seven eight percent so far today
what what's your feeling about bitcoins
price going into the having I mean at
dude and just to give some context here
pomp and I would literally watch Bitcoin
just like we're doing it now with you at
Starbucks or dunks like all day long
like I can look at these candles and go
from like the five minute to the
four-hour candle all day like I got to
tell a story though it's 2,000 in
probably no little it probably 2017 this
is right when I think in 17 if I
remember correctly ether went from $10
at the start of the
you're jumped to 30 I like March and by
May it wasn't like $100 like it was here
we go right and we have been lining yeah
and I remember we were sitting at
Starbucks off of I don't know somewhere
in Raleigh Strickland you had on the
construction vest and we're sitting
there we had our computers out and we
had the charts up we were just like what
the hell is happening basically and we
just couldn't believe what was going on
and people were walking by to get coffee
and they were like those guys are
ridiculous or crazy or both like they
literally did not understand what was
going on because of how we were dressed
that we had the computers up charge so
big all this stuff and I remember like
then we would have people that we knew
come stop by so like guys like Jim pride
like all these people would come and
stop by we were just like wait a minute
like is this their office it was
ridiculous and then random people would
would come up to us and say hey can you
give us some investment divided advice
you know I mean I'm interested in with
you're dressed like this I'm in a
reflective vest and we're giving people
tips on early-stage venture and encrypt
I know that it was really a lot of fun
not much has changed though to be honest
we're still kind of working in the
similar environment and of course some
people are asking
let's get this out of the way about your
jerseys in the background they want to
know what jerseys are yes so I'm a huge
Manchester United fan so there's a
solski our Jersey he's the coach for
Manchester United's sign that was a gift
from a friend in real life and on crypto
and then the the the number 7 there is
Eric Cantona so I fell in love with him
when I saw him jump into the stands and
kick a fan who was heckling him during a
game I just thought that was the wildest
thing I've ever seen and then I've got
another Manchester United Jersey over
here that's signed by a bunch of teams a
bunch of the players so yeah I'm a big
soccer fan dad's from Manchester England
my mom's Sicilian I played semi-pro
soccer and
in south america Pomp's come and see me
play before i'm the king of the over 30
league yeah that is true
Jason is uh still athletic for for being
old now if not old it's a bit faster and
crazier than everybody you know when
when you're a kid and you think that
like man twenties old then you guys at
twenty you're like man forties old and
then you get to forty eight and I'm sure
you're like 70s old right right it all
well relative yeah but look if you take
care of yourself you can still you know
do the things that that you want to do
and I love playing soccer and screwing
around so I'm gonna try to do it every
day if I can yeah people are asking what
we actually think the having is going to
do so maybe let's start with the
short-term price prediction and then we
can talk about the longer-term
implications Publisher your general idea
on what's gonna happen short term you go
first short term I think that there's
probably little effect if anything at
all if there is movement it might be
down a little bit just from people
selling after speculating but I
generally think that it's gonna go
sideways for a while and in hindsight
will be a relative non-event I do not
believe that it's going to run off right
so I'm kind of have the highest
conviction it won't go up second highest
conviction or just go sideways and then
a third is there might be a little bit
of downward price pressure do you trade
no I mean I think these are and look I
catching a lot of heat for posting
trades and stuff online I just think
that's absolutely ridiculous and you
know some dudes are like you're gonna
get kneecap tour mugged and stuff just
think about what you're saying every day
Warren Buffett or someone goes on TV and
says I just bought 10% of American
Airlines or the whole airline industry
people don't Rob him at that point you
know when the Tim Draper bought 30,000
Bitcoin for 18 million dollars from the
feds people didn't mug him for his
Bitcoin you know so I
doing this because I I really don't like
when people play this game of I'm doing
this I'm selling that I'm buying that
you don't know what these guys are
actually doing so for me when I say I'm
buying Bitcoin and I say I bought two
Bitcoin or five Bitcoin or ten Bitcoin
I'm just saying look I'm really doing
this I'm really putting my money at work
so you know how do I feel this this
Bitcoin like reward having countdown
thing is gonna affect the price I've
been pretty vocal about the fact that I
I'm surprised it's at the price it is
right now I actually thought about kind
of a pre having pump and maybe that's
what this is and then you know I've been
really focused on minor capitulation
because I think that's real pump and I
think after the having the the strong
hands and mining are gonna absolutely
decimate those that are trying to hang
on in any way and really try to clear
them out so they get maximum reward for
each block so this this this is going to
be interesting I think she'd be a lot of
pressure on the price of Bitcoin and a
real opportunity if you have a low time
preference to put money at work and I've
been waiting what I've been waiting to
do that
so explain might or capitulation there's
a lot of people who probably don't
understand what that is what do you
think is the best way to describe that
yes so mining is very very expensive you
have a operational expense that you have
to secure in the form of power depending
on where you are in the world power
could be anywhere from two cents one
cent five six cents a kilowatt-hour then
you have to commit to your hardware so
to mine Bitcoin you use ASIC miners and
those are expensive right now for s17
ss-19
this 19's probably cost two to three
thousand dollars depending on the amount
you're buying each you've got to deploy
them in an environment that's stable so
the best in the world have almost like
tier three tier
to data centers that they're putting
these these miners in and they're
managing the heat and power in a very
formulaic way and they're getting
tremendous efficiencies but those who
are kind of speculating around the
periphery and I call them kind of
chicken coop miners so they've got maybe
a conics container and they're they're
ramming fresh air in and there's not a
lot of well there's some science there
but it's not sophisticated they've got
maybe s nines running still or they've
they're in some kind of a transition but
the inefficiencies are there maybe
they're paying high cost of power the
having is a brutal event it takes the
the block reward down by half and when
that happens you have this this revenue
hit so imagine if you're you have a
pizzeria and today in an hour no matter
what you're doing no matter how many
pizzas you're selling that price of
pizza goes down by half you're gonna
have to make some pretty dramatic
decisions to maintain making pizzas and
that's what the the miners have to do or
they have to shut up shut down yeah
there's this element of as the hardware
gets upgraded right so the s nines
aren't going to be profitable what's
because of this having for most people
because their cost is too high a certain
percentage of the network is already
upgraded to s 17s I've seen estimates as
high as 75% of the network or so is the
thought process that the remaining 25%
they just go away like actually
disappear do they shut off and then come
back with new equipment like what
happens to the people who haven't
upgraded yet how do you think about that
well I think and I think it's a high
number not a small number so that's
something you and I have really gone
back and forth about you know let's use
a Pareto principle and say 20% of the
miners that are still here are
inefficient miners it could be higher
and I do believe it's higher but let's
say 20% are inefficient miners they have
they have resource constraint
and challenges all over the place pomp
they probably couldn't take loans to
upgrade their equipment they could raise
equity to upgrade their equipment they
probably have high cost power ppas and a
PPA stands for a purchase power
agreement and you just can't come in and
out of an agreement like that you may
have um like a month-to-month contract
if you're really good but you could have
a three six or 12 month contract and
just imagine hitting the wall here
capital constrained haven't upgraded
your your hardware and you're sitting in
a PPA you're blasting through any
reserves you have in crypto that's why
you were here right it was to create
some arbitrage if I mine one Bitcoin
only use three three-quarters of it to
pay my bills but now you've had to sell
it all it's a it totally sucks
and you're done and that that's that's
kind of the capitulation that occurs
yeah see you guys in the comments
bullshitting about my blender cup leave
me the hell alone
this comes the biggest cup I got in my
house so I use it because it carries the
most water stay hydrated or drink Miller
Lite like Jason yeah are you still uh
are you still eating those or drinking
those green drinks green drinks what was
that yeah what is that thing yeah I'd
like them what what is it
I don't every vegetable everybody knows
that I eat like [ __ ] but Glen has been
trying to convince me to be eaten
shoutout to McDonald's I don't even know
very many adults that eat at McDonald's
like you do and it's not right what
you're doing a polina now I play that
she listen she likes McDonald's
periodically she's not exactly a fan of
it all the time yeah but I mean that
that can't be your favorite restaurant
it's definitely my favorite it's the
best restaurant in America here's why
consistent food production low cost and
you always know what you're gonna get
that's it isn't it like pop pop isn't it
like one in four or one in five
Americans have worked at McDonald's
probably I don't know I never worked at
McDonald's I worked at a chick-fil-a in
Quiznos when I was younger but the the
amount of people that have been employed
by McDonald's and just that that
represents the American population is
staggering
it really is I think it's one in five
all right listen I agree I for those
that uh I see a bunch of people also
saying that just because we don't eat
healthy that we need to go to the gym
Jason and I will out lift any of you
everyone relax you even lift bro alright
so another thing that people are asking
about is institutional adoption for
Bitcoin obviously we had the recent news
about Paul Tudor Jones getting kind of
1/2 percent exposure through the
derivatives market kind of what I
thought that was fascinating actually
why I don't know it just seemed like for
a conservative guy like that and and you
can go into his background now you've
read some books have you read his book
no I've never read does he have a book I
haven't read it if he does I the best
piece of content on them by far is uh
there's a documentary on YouTube
I think called traitor are just Google
Paul Tudor Jones traitor and it's really
good I think like an hour long and it
follows him around in like the mid 80s
and he's just like a super southern dude
who he looks at as a game right and I
think that is taught at the time the CIO
says something like I think Paul's like
30 to 33 years older and the documentary
his CIO is 27 and he's like look man I
used to play backgammon and chess all
the time and when I was in college
somebody was like you like these types
of games I'll show you another game that
is completely reliant on you making or
losing lots of money on every decision
let me teach you about stock futures
that's how he got into it which is
pretty as fascinating to me it's
incredible I mean what is he worth 20
billion dollars I mean that's I would he
has a um he manages 22 billion I think
give or take right and I don't want to
be presumptuous but he said he has one
to two percent of of his money at work
in Bitcoin yeah so I think I think he's
worth like 5 billion and he's got 22
billion in assets so call it he's by
somewhere in the three to five hundred
million dollar range
of assets in in Bitcoin right now and is
he holding physical Bitcoin or is he how
is he making that putting that money to
work no I think he's doing it through
the futures market he's not buying
actual Bitcoin it makes sense from a
perspective of he appears to understand
the argument for Bitcoin he appears to
understand why people are interested in
it but he doesn't yet believe that it's
gonna be a global reserve currency so
what he's doing is basically speculating
on price which is really what you know
if people are really honest with
themselves most people got into Bitcoin
originally because of price and then
they kind of I think it's a Parker at
Unchained Capital stays like come for
the money stay for the money you come
from a capitalistic price movement
standpoint and then you begin to learn
about money the economy the financial
markets inflation you know all that kind
of stuff and you end up staying because
of the sound money I think that's
probably what happens here with him
right is he comes to make money from a
training perspective but ends up
learning a lot about it I was shocked by
his kind of and I'm not surprised
because he's obviously a brilliant guy
but his vision on the digitization of
things you know he kind of got into that
a little bit I hope he comes back and
and talks a little bit more about that
because it's such a important and
fundamental like underpinning of anyone
who's investing in the space you have to
believe in like computers speaking to
computers right yeah well and I think
part of it is you know as you think
about the digitization so those that
don't know Jason and I kind of our core
thesis along with Mark is every stock
bond currency commodity will be
digitized over time and you're already
starting to see this and in different
aspects someone that will be with
blockchain technology some of it won't
be Bitcoin is obviously the first kind
of digital currency that we're seeing
that play out with it sounded like Paul
Tudor Jones is way down that road
already which is pretty encouraging and
my guess is that as a trader today he
doesn't have a lot of assets where he
can speculate on
so bitcoin is one of those but over time
as other assets get digitized like he'll
start to incorporate those as well and
you know look at some point in the
future I don't know if it's 10 years or
50 years from now a hundred percent of
his portfolio and every other person's
portfolio is gonna be digital right
it'll all be digital stocks bonds
currencies and commodities big questions
just when does that actually happen and
do the people who are early to that
trend do they benefit you know in an
outsized way how do the futures markets
work as compared to just holding
physical Bitcoin well I think futures in
general is the best way to think about
this if you know nothing about finance
is you're betting on the future price of
an asset so you basically enter into a
contracts let's say that Jason and I are
both in the market jason says I will
sell you a contract at a future price on
a future date so let's just say $10,000
on June 30th right I can then go in and
say you know what I think that bitcoin
is going to be worth more than $10,000
by June 30th and so in that case I will
buy that contract from Jason he's
obligated to sell me Bitcoin at $10,000
on that date now in the meet can I
interrupt you for a second so at that
point I have to take physical possession
of that Bitcoin or sell the contract to
someone else yes technically you can
have a cash settled or physically
settled physically settled contracts
mean that the bitcoins actually
transacted at the end a cash settled
future just means we're betting on the
price but you never actually bought
Bitcoin and neither did I we just settle
up at the end what the difference in the
money is so the reason I like to explore
that is can you can you relate that
exact scenario to what happened in oil
recently oil is uh
I mean I don't there's nobody in the
world
I think and I mean when oil went to
minus $37 a contract yeah
so most I don't know oil basically the
way that you can buy it is through three
different methods you can actually buy
all directly you know it like a stock
that tracks the price of oil
there's four ways you can buy oil you
can buy a stock that tracks the the
price of oil you can buy a physically
settled futures contract or a
cash-settled futures contract
cash-settled futures contract is the
same thing i just described where let's
say that I'm holding a ten dollar
contract oil today is at $12 when it
ends Jason has to pay me $2 right the
difference between that what I paid and
what it's worth today what happened in
with physically settled oil contracts is
that the whoever's holding it on the day
of expert expiration they have to accept
delivery of physical oil physical
delivery of the oil yeah so literally
shows up in barrels right or in a
reservoir and so what happened in April
was the may contract it obviously it
settles a couple of days before you have
to deliver her to receive delivery so
the day before it was supposed to expire
everyone started to panic a little bit
and then the all of a sudden it went
from I'll sell this contract to anybody
at ten dollars nobody wanted to buy it
from me because if they bought it that
day they'd have to accept delivery so
then I said I'll sell it for nine four
eight four seven four five actually you
know what I'll just give it to somebody
they don't have to pay me any money zero
dollars I'll just give it to them still
nobody would come take it from me and so
then people went negative meaning I said
to Jason I'll give you ten dollars if
you take this contract hey Jase don't
give me $20 so you'd be $30 are you
fifty dollars at one point that day if
you take this contract so not only will
I pay you $50 to take the contract you
also are gonna get all the oil that's
gonna get delivered as well and so
ultimately it comes down to like why
would somebody not want oil if they're
getting paid to take it and it's because
they literally don't have anywhere to
sport right yeah I knew Papa I I heard
there were like barges floating around
in the ocean absolutely maxed out in oil
there's nowhere to physically receive
oil okay there's there's no demand and
everyone knows why that's happened
because we've shut down the global
economy yeah and also there's a bunch of
we'll just call it you know kind of
screwing around
[Music]
that you know look Russia or Saudi
Arabia they all disagree on a bunch of
this stuff
I always joke actually in the Paul Tudor
Jones documentary this is a hilarious so
one point he's talking about OPEC and
he's talking about he's betting there's
a rumor that OPEC is gonna come to an
agreement and he says I'm just you know
like a kid from Kentucky basically and
you're telling me thirteen people about
a go in a room and come out with an
agreement
I'll bet against that all day long right
and so he basically makes a financial
investment on the idea that OPEC is not
going to come to an agreement and so a
couple minutes later in the documentary
they say OPEC has reached a deal except
for two people aren't going to abide by
the deal great and he literally says in
there he goes that was a hard bet and
he's like kind of laughing about it but
ultimately like that's what happens in
the oil market right as OPEC is I think
it's 13 countries I may be wrong on that
who come together and they make
agreements how much oil is everyone
gonna produce how do we not flood the
market to drive down price and and all
this stuff in Saudi Arabia basically saw
an opportunity to flood the market and
really to break the back of a lot of
these oil producers because they aren't
able to produce oil as cheaply as Saudi
Arabia so I think Saudi can do it at
like two or three dollars six bucks yeah
they can take oil out of the ground for
six bucks and Russia has made claim that
at 25 dollars US a barrel they could
they could survive for ten years and I
agree with you it almost seems like
China the Middle East Russia they can
all fire this economic shot at the u.s.
because as you know the u.s. is the
world's largest oil producer at this
time and we certainly don't produce oil
at the economics that these other
countries do so it's a crippling
situation and and one that is
multifaceted and geopolitically
connected absolutely before we keep
going real quick couple of housekeeping
things one hey let me interrupt you I
just one of my one of my limit orders
just hit on gem and I 8,500 8,500 I
I got other ones 8,500 you guys wanted
to know if we're buying today or not
there's your answer
so a couple of things one if you can
smash the like button right underneath
the lobby send in that Bitcoin over to
block Phi to get interest hit the like
button leave a comment if you have any
questions we'll get our go we'll go for
another two hours or so so we'll do our
best to try to answer those questions
for you make sure you're subscribed to
the channel so that you can get
notifications when we post other videos
and then we have two sponsors for today
both Gemini and black Phi you talk about
Gemini this time I get in talking about
block yeah so
Gemini started by the Winklevoss twins
again and FDI fdic-insured they have
other types of insurance to protect your
crypto hot wallet connect your bank to
Gemini and great place to trade they
have a mobile app that's that's I think
has a great ui/ux
I think we have a link to the mobile app
also that you may want to put up at some
point pause in the comments I'll keep
posting it in the comments but go check
them out there yeah so beyond that they
have a bunch of pairs now so they've
evolved beyond just trading you know
Ethan Bitcoin and you know I think that
it's super slick interface user
experience is great and oh thanks very
much okay yes hey do you have the box
the box yeah I just got my pizza son
it's got my pizza and I use that have
you ever use shipping I think it's
called shipping no what's that so I
think it's called shipping say thanks
that's it thanks shipping is ginger yeah
that's the gangsta that's a 12 year old
versus ship you got to get her she's not
ready she's not ready yet a 12 year old
versus ship so for those that don't know
is Jason's 12 year old daughter recently
bought a little bit of Bitcoin with some
money that she earned and
take a picture and started tweeting at
Peter Schiff that his 12 year old is
smarter than Peter Schiff and as you can
imagine
Peter free took the bait he took the
bait look and it's a great great
opportunity to kind of teach you know
your kids or you know around about kind
of just financing and how how money
works and she's caught the bug man she
loves it and she's got a little business
pressure-washing she uses that money to
buy Bitcoin which is cool but ya know so
anyway this this shipping I think it's
called ship and it you can you can get
groceries delivered to your house and I
use it like Target and I just I just
wanted to test it out so I asked
somebody get me some like Kido Kido
friendly pizza or gluten free pizza just
try it so you know I got this this quest
I don't know I've never tried it man
frozen pizza you know one bite everyone
knows the rules
thin crust uncured pepperoni gluten free
six net carbs so it's keto friendly and
I'm like I'm gonna give it a try we'll
see you see how this goes if you want
real pizza just ordered Domino's they
never they never fail dude I have to
give it to them you know you said
something that's so right if you order
Domino's Pizza there their website is
awesome like it literally has all these
kind of bells and whistles going off it
tells you when the the cheese is on the
pizza and the sauce and and when it when
it hits the delivery and it's on the
road it's pretty interesting yeah it's
the whole idea is the mobile ordering is
so great and then you know we're talking
about earlier today but Starbucks same
thing mobile ordering completely changes
the game for a lot of these these
businesses so I think you know it's I
think Chipotle now is is starting to do
that and we'll see more the other by the
way before I forget the other sponsor is
blocked by as you guys know we are huge
fans of block Phi
we're investors in the business they
sponsor the podcast and the whole idea
behind block Phi is you can basically do
three things you can put crypto in and
take a u.s.
loan against your collateral you can put
crypto into an interest-bearing account
your crypto is held with Gemini and lent
out on the backend you can earn up to
eight point six percent a py and they
also have a crypto currency exchange you
can buy and sell crypto there as well we
you know - in terms of how we talk about
these businesses so people a lot of
times will ask me what goes on in the
institutional investor room right when
that door closes what is the
conversation like and I think people see
us having fun on Twitter and joking
around a lot and stuff but they know
that obviously we're not gonna walk in
in t-shirts and stuff into those rooms
and so what the conversation basically
happens is first of all we wear suits
and ties which is pretty funny but on
top of that we basically say there's
three things one every stock one
currency Kimani is going to be digitized
in the future two is all of the same
regulations apply to crypto that apply
to your traditional financial assets and
three is there's a lot of really really
valuable powerful companies that are
being built in the space that can
provide very unique opportunities and so
gemini block fire two great examples
gemini obviously has incredible security
they've gone through multiple sock
audits and and they you know probably
more than any other crypto exchange I
think understand that trust is the
product like if people trust you they're
willing to use you and so they stay up
they stay running they've got high
levels of security and and I think that
really highlights the people you know
kind of how serious they're taking
regulation and security which really
puts institutional investors at ease and
then we block by like we've literally
told multiple multibillion-dollar asset
managers people who manage billions of
dollars that they should go find their
cash position they should take 5% of
their cash they could go deposit it in
an interest-bearing account with block
five and earn up to eight point six
percent APY Jason and I both do it
we told institutions to do it it's a
no-brainer because most people's money
market account they're earning one to
one and a half percent if you're leaving
in like our attritional savings or
checking account
you're probably earning less
50 basis points and if all of a sudden
you can take that your cash is held in
an fdic-insured State Street account gem
and I will issue you either G USD or USD
C you can use as well and you deposit an
interest-bearing account or 8.6% I keep
saying over and over again like the
stock markets down this year you could
have made more by simply putting your
money an interest-bearing account than
investing in stocks and so I just tend
to think that over long periods of time
an interest-bearing account that pays
8.6 percent is going to drastically
outperform equities for the next ten
years for sure and also is likely to
outperform other asset classes as well
and it's relatively low risk obviously
go do your own research all of that but
for a UH for the amount of diligence
that we've done we're super comfortable
with it and I think it's a great
opportunity yeah I mean I've said
publicly I probably have 99 percent of
my cash in three or four vehicles I have
some cash
Fiat dollars I have us G USD in block
Phi and then I Bitcoin you know and I
look at those as like liquid kind of
positions for me and to be able earn
interest on that is is is like icing the
block fly investment with G USD it
rivals kind of real estate yeah you know
if it holds up you have this liquid semi
liquid position in in a stable token
getting 8.6 percent Interest you know
depending on where you are and you're
kind of like wealth creation curve that
may be enough like why take the risk of
a stock market yeah actually let's talk
about that a little bit you and I
probably a lot of people don't hear us
talk about from like a financial
education and wealth creation standpoint
I think that there's a lot of people I
would put there's three buckets of
investors right that are encrypted one
is super sophisticated either
individuals or institutions they are
absolutely professionals this is what
they do for a living they're highly
educated have tons of experience access
to data etc then you've got a group of
people who I would put above average
in sophistication they understand how
money works they understand kind of how
to build wealth and they're going down
that path they're not yet at the large
institution large individual level and
they've got a lot of people probably the
majority actually at the market but
there's actually relatively uneducated
about finance about how money works how
the economy works and and how to build
wealth maybe let's spend a couple of
minutes just talking through like how
you and your life have thought about
wealth building and kind of the steps to
take in terms of maybe not guaranteeing
that you'll get wealthy but at least
increasing the probability of building
wealth by not making mistakes and really
being patient over a long period yeah so
in kind of my personal journey if you
would have asked my real estate excuse
me my my accountant back in the day you
know was Jason a urgent-care
entrepreneur or real estate developer
he'd say I was a real estate developer
because my early kind of for way into
business was to build a business like
fast med that could afford to pay a
mortgage but leveraged that business to
acquire real estate so I was buying you
know Blockbuster Video stores or banks
or post offices and cities and then
leveraging fast meant to pay that
mortgage it was a high leverage kind of
high risk situation but as an
owner-occupied kind of entrepreneur I
understood the strength of of my own
balance sheet and my earning potentials
and I was willing to to risk that and I
also had youth on my side I was what
twenty five years old when I started so
um wasn't married no kids young high
leverage but a real estate thesis and
what what that's done over you know many
years now fifteen years twenty years
later is you have all these pieces of
property Tier one pieces of property
renting or leasing in in in the health
care space that you never paid any
mortgage payments on you leveraged the
business you may have sold that business
to private equity backed urgent care
business that now you know is continuing
to pay that rent
so I look at the beginning of my own
kind of wealth creation was in real
estate actually I still owned those
properties a number of those properties
even though I've sold fast med and they
they pay like an annuity and I've I've
tried to teach that to people that I go
into business with and you and I have
been successful in doing some of that in
our career together as well I think it's
a it's a easy hack if you are a if you
have a good business and you need a
physical a physical space rather than
renting maybe by yeah well it's also I
think that people forget the beauty of
leverage right especially if from an
investment property standpoint if you're
able to basically buy a property put the
down payment down and then you never
make one of the monthly payments on the
mortgage instead you have a renter who
is who's doing that whether it's a
business or individuals or multiple
individuals
it's just leverage on your cash right
and over a long period of time you end
up owning a hundred percent of the
property but you use somebody else's
money to do it and obviously you've got
to be careful about the risk you take
and kind of how much leverage you put on
things make sure you're buying good
property whatever but I do think that
having that long time horizon really
helps right yeah I mean putting fifteen
to twenty percent down on this piece of
property and then leveraging the rest
could it's it's worked for me and us
historically but again you have to do
your own research on this one
I'm not a big leverage guy so I other
than real estate for summaries and it's
um it's interesting and something to
explore at some point you know I don't
like dad I don't like credit cards I
don't even like running businesses with
debt startups etc but for some reason I
don't mind using some leverage on real
estate I mean have you ever have you
ever thought about why you'll tolerate
that or maybe you you like using
leverage and other real estate or other
investment opportunities well I think
that so I used to be of the belief that
like leverage and debt was really bad
right and it kind of all problem stemmed
from leverage and debt I think over time
as I've talked to more
or super experienced investors where I
come out on it now is it's only bad if
you abuse it right it's kind of like
what my favorite life mottos is anything
worth doing is worth overdoing
but there's an asterisks on that which
is except in finance
which is you know you can very quickly
go yo someone pulled the rug out of
Bitcoin what happened
just broke 8400 where is it going it's
going
Mesa's hello while we're on this
livestream how low do you think Bitcoin
goes man so now I may get in trouble for
restating this because I already got
reprimanded a little bit about this
earlier you know but I've been saying
that you know I expect I expected
Bitcoin - to be around 6,800 going
through the having that could be before
or after and I've made some large
purchases at a much higher number than
6,800 and people are like oh that
doesn't make any sense why are you
buying Bitcoin at at 9,000 if you think
it's going to 6,800 I'm dca you know I'm
not certain it's going to 6,800 and I'm
just hitting it with dry powder each
time I'm not selling Bitcoin so I've got
Bitcoin at 9,000 I got Bitcoin at 3,000
I got you know whatever the prices are
but it's all just new allocations yeah
it's um it is this thing where when it
comes to Bitcoin again just like real
estate like I actually explained Bitcoin
sometimes to people as real estate I say
look why does land why are people so
excited about land right it's this whole
idea of they're not gonna make more of
it and so they're not gonna make more of
it and more people want it supply demand
economics takeover price goes up over
time also the fiat currency gets
devalued against it and so it takes more
fiat currency to buy that same piece of
property the longer you wait right
bitcoins gonna be no different and it's
proven that way over the last 11 years
and so I think that the dca model is I
mean again mathematically proven I think
now there are certain things that you
can go in and like if you started buying
at the top of the market of 2017 and you
dc-8 for the last three years you would
still be up today right
and it's just but when you see things
like that you know one of the biggest
lessons I think I've learned over the
last couple of years is financial
returns really is all about asset
allocation more so than it is about
individual investments right it's all
about the discipline and strategy and if
you nail that you can make mistakes and
in the short-term and be fine why are
your eyes man
bitcoins bitcoins dumpin like lactose
intolerance person eating a bunch of ice
cream listen
somebody asked in the comments what if
anything do we ever argue about and I
was sitting here thinking I honestly
think the only thing that Jason and I
have ever argued about is the Bitcoin
price what's gonna happen next and like
I can't think of anything else and it's
always a debate on is so many inputs and
you're really putting different
weightings on all the different inputs
and so we come out to different
conclusions all the time yeah I mean I
tend to III think you have a very good
approach at how you assess the space
because of your you're super low time
preference and neither of us are traders
so you know this is really just about
when to buy because I don't think that
we've really explored when to sell yeah
we've thought a little bit about it but
I don't
I can't tell like it what number would
you sell Bitcoin I honestly don't think
I'd sell see you know and I I think I
learned a really valuable lesson from
mark of around rebalancing because I
think rebalancing is important
especially if you if you are overweight
in US in any position or get overweight
simply because you've had a big success
I mean how can you say you'll never sell
I mean what if Bitcoin hits the numbers
that some of the people that we respect
have like hypothecated like Plan B
saying that Bitcoin could could
potentially you know hit 288 thousand by
2024 you wouldn't re allocate your
position you'd hold no I would count
because you've been validated in so many
ways by that happening it's almost now
like this is this is too easy and how a
lot of AG's feel about the fact that
bitcoins at 8300 right now when they
were in at a dollar I think there's two
aspects the first is again structurally
right you know the story but for those
that don't know I once asked Mort usko
you know right when we first started
working together I said hey you pretty
much spent most of the last 20 years
talking to the absolute best investors
in the world maimie named an investor on
Wall Street who is one of the best and
mark knows them right he spent time he's
even given them money as an LP and so I
said to him look you've interviewed all
of them right in terms of potentially
giving them capital what separates the
top five from the top one percent so the
best of the best of the best from just
the best and he said one thing very
easily he's at the absolute five best in
the world
cut their losers faster than anyone else
and they press they're winners harder
than anyone else
and I think like that's like seared in
my brain one but also two is you know I
look at this in a very I think nuanced
yet unique way which is the only reason
I'm interested in Bitcoin is because I
fundamentally believe it will be the
next global reserve currency right and
when I say that in like the
institutional rooms they literally are
like you're absolutely insane but
there's zero chance of that happening
doesn't that melt down the United States
at that point though I mean just the
well okay why do you think it does well
I mean isn't being isn't having the
global reserve currency status like
super important and there's a bunch of
other super powers in the world that
don't have the global reserve status
well they had it and lost it well Russia
never had it China great Great Britain
had it yeah I think the British sterling
and I think it took a world war to
displace them some would say it's there
they lost grip on it in the 20s but
I think maybe World War two knocked them
out yeah like my whole thought process
with this though is every currency
that's ever failed from global reserve
status when they failed it was due to
conflict right so when the goal way back
to Rome the pound whatever they they all
fail because they got devalued to the
point of weakness somebody sees that
weakness came in and crushed either the
economy the population or both right the
difference here is when you move to a
digital world war is not going to be
fought eighty to eighty two hundred I'm
sorry to interrupt you minute this rice
brought to you by Gemini this is like
wild man all right keep going down but
let's see yeah just keep going sorry I'm
keeping wars gonna be fought very
differently right we're not gonna fight
with bombs and bullets like we used to
instead there's gonna be much more cyber
war that goes on but the difference
between physical war and cyber war is in
the cyber realm the best offense doesn't
win actually the best defense wins and
what I mean by that is when you're at
war in the physical sphere if I just
come and I shoot you I win you lose
right it's very kind of binary and it's
all about military might here in the
digital world what ends up happening is
whoever has the best defense can prevent
an attack and even if let's say the
United States hacked let's say China's
electrical grid if they kicked us out
and we never got back in then China
actually wins right because they have a
bigger defense than they then we do an
offense and so in the cyber world like
who has the strongest computing network
are the best security the Bitcoin
network is the strongest computer in the
world so in a cyber war bitcoin is the
dominant military force if you think of
it from that perspective because of that
what ends up happening is every
nation-state can attack it it doesn't
matter right they will still remain the
strongest in the world because of the
decentralized nature and so as we move
to this digital world a currency the
next reserve currency is going to have
to have the strongest defense Bitcoin
has that and so the reason why I am so
heavily allocated to it is
I actually think that there's a greater
than 50% chance that Bitcoin will be the
next global reserve currency that seems
like a big number but I always say to
people okay do you believe that the US
dollar will be remained that global
reserve currency forever
most people say I don't know when it
will end
but at some point in the future even if
it's a thousand years from now at some
point it ends but but but most of them
they last about a hundred years right so
something like that yeah something like
that
and we're like 80 years or I don't know
how long it's been 60 years something
like that
yeah it depends on when you account from
for sure but but it's it's nothing been
decades right and so if you believe that
the US dollars not going to be the
global reserve currency forever then my
question becomes okay what replaces it
and today there's two answers a currency
that already exists or a currency that
doesn't yet exist most people can't
comprehend a currency that doesn't exist
will then replace and be the next global
reserve currency so they look in the
bucket of currencies that exist and then
I say to them okay let's start with fiat
what fiat currency that currently exists
today will end up being the global
reserve currency nine out of ten times
people will say the Chinese currency
right that's like the go-to if not that
they say I don't see one and so my point
here is I do not believe that we are
going to have a sovereign currency as
the next reserve currency simply because
none of these other countries will allow
it where the days of this are of kind of
a currency backing or a state backing of
currency I think are over the dollar has
a long runway we're going to get a
separation of state and money and when
we enter a digital world i think bitcoin
ends up being the winner
yeah but pom could and you may have just
said this so if I'm restating this just
confirm it could Bitcoin exist outside
of the the even the global reserve
currency status but be something that is
is used by nations to transact and do
business outside of their currency
simply it's like a hedge against [ __ ]
of course I actually think that this is
in stages right so
right now let's put it you have in the
world basically 99.9% fiat currency 0.1%
digital currency right and that digital
currency is dominated you know 60 70
percent by Bitcoin in my opinion you are
likely to get coexistence in the next 10
to 20 years meaning that you have fiat
currencies and you have Bitcoin those
fiat currencies will become digitized so
you have a digital dollar digital wan
digital yen digital euro or whatever and
you'll have Bitcoin when you get to
parody on the technology stack now the
competition is not on the technology
layer because you're already at parity
everyone has the same technology you
then get to a competition at the
monetary policy level the US China
Russia India the euro anybody in the
world they cannot change their monetary
policy structure they can change the
decisions but they can't change the
structure they they are locked into an
inflationary system and so ultimately
what I think people will choose is
they'll choose a transparent
programmatic monetary policy and I
always go back to like you will trust
algorithms over humans right we already
do that people when they get lost in a
new city they ask Google Maps they don't
ask somebody on the street corner
anymore if you have a question you don't
ask your friend you ask Google you want
a music recommendations Spotify and
Apple music give it to you not your
buddy right and so in that those are all
non-financial type things so that
they're important right physically where
am I going what am i listening to
whatever but slowly but surely will
start to do that in the financial system
as well we'll just trust the machines
right like the Machine overlords are
coming the beauty is we still are in
control the machines to some degree and
I think that bitcoin ends up winning and
therefore I have a high risk tolerance
because that's my belief and I'm young
enough like that's the other key piece
right is I'm young enough where I could
lose everything today and I actually
think that I'd make more money if that
happened then if I didn't lose
everything today right and so it's just
like when you come from that mentality
it's like look this is seems pretty you
know [ __ ] high probability in my
opinion let's let it roll
what did you think about what Vladimir
Putin said about crypto and Bitcoin when
asked about a state-sponsored
cryptocurrency yeah that was um six
blocks left for those that are keeping
pace at home about an hour out give or
take
so I think that first of all that videos
from 2018 he's got a somebody put it to
me it's a morning talk show that makes
Putin look good or a weekly talk show
that makes Putin look good he takes
questions from citizens and communism
yeah
and he basically shows off his
intelligence right by the way it's very
obvious he's incredibly intelligent
right from a raw horsepower standpoint
and somebody asked them you know hey do
we need to worry about digitizing our
currency or will Russia ever create a
crypto currency and Putin basically
answers those guys well it's impossible
for us to create a crypto currency
because a crypto currency is
decentralized and like it's in Russia's
best interest and never to have a
decentralized thing that because we
would want control right and in a
paraphrase he was basically said so one
he definitely understands is way better
than people originally thought two is
there's game theory at play right where
countries are gonna have to go through
that game theory and I think ultimately
where you get is I think it's Unchained
capital they're a series that Parker
writes is like slowly but then suddenly
right which is everyone is uh it's kind
of like everyone sitting in a room and
they all have guns pointed at each other
and no one wants to be the first to
shoot right cuz the first person to
shoot is definitely getting killed you
start with just pointing their gun at
each other but the first time a central
bank says hey we've bought Bitcoin and
put in our reserves or a country says
hey we're going to adopt Bitcoin and
like I got an actual real big country
says we're gonna adopt Bitcoin as a
national currency or we're gonna use it
for bilateral trade everyone's gonna
have to do it but what about China
though it seems like China has made a
move into a digital currency and they
seem to be testing it like McDonald's
and Pizza Hut and I mean it unless
that's fake news oh they're definitely
testing it I have no doubt about that I
think that maybe they and I and you have
very different ideas about what we're
optimizing for right all right well
explain I think
they're optimizing for surveillance
right there trying to usher in a case
like this is like track and trace but
with money
yeah I mean look the governments around
the world have found it incredibly
valuable to be able to control and track
money right you know any crime movie you
watch what do they do they follow the
money right and and so Bitcoin kind of
like a crappy way to pull off heists and
stuff I mean it's not a very good you
still want to use cash right if you want
to do something nefarious or I don't
think Bitcoin is a great thing to use in
its current state to commit crimes
actually think it's a really really bad
thing to use before I you know you can
be traced in terms of cash we know two
trillion dollars a year is laundered you
know and used for all kinds of nefarious
purposes I still crack up when I saw
secretary mentioned go on CNBC and hit
joke mention yeah what what's his name I
think it's an urchin we mean [ __ ]
whatever listen but I don't know what
his name is man venusian that you got
Jerry stock picker and Jerome Powell
you've got Stevie money printer in the
Treasury for Satoshi
I'll take Satoshi all day long I like
the names I love the names it's because
you're here's what's going on and this
is the part that like I get super
passionate about because you and I are
in a position where we're fortunate
enough to understand what's happening
right knowledge is power in this
scenario but what has occurred over the
last I don't know six eight weeks is two
things one the US government bought the
piece of people they bribed the people
into not having social unrest 1,200
bucks yeah a listing of that investment
we're gonna give everybody and by the
way only a certain percentage of people
got 1,200 bucks most people got bless
and anyone who made over 100k got
nothing right so they basically bought
for a couple hundred billion dollars
that they invented out if they were a
print out of thin air and gave to people
they bought social peace right so
there's no unrest and then on top of
that they then went and they printed
another call it 1.7 trillion - so a
total of more than two trillion dollars
and they started handing it out to
people and so it's literally like a drug
and they're doing all of this but what
they're doing is talking about PPP PPP
all the stimulus everything that they
bailouts all this stuff they've printed
so much money they've expanded the
federal balance sheet the Federal
Reserve balance sheet by 50-plus percent
in six weeks and all they're doing is
they're robbing people who don't
understand like the US financial system
is based on 50 percent or more of the
population not understanding how money
works and they're using that to their
advantage they are literally stealing
the wealth from the bottom 50% in us
that I saw yesterday was 55 percent of
Americans own stock either directly like
they put it into a trading account they
bought it whether it's Robin Hood or
Charles Schwab or whatever
retirement account so big big number 45%
own no stock big number and so guess who
just got screwed the bottom forty five
percent of Americans cuz guess what's
happening the economic data is getting
worse and worse but the stock markets
rally but it's being propped up right of
course they're just enriching their
friends right and here's my favorite
part how much do you think Jerome Powell
is worth bro these guys are these guys
are not there it's amazing forty million
more of these rogue I think he's worth
over fifty million dollars incredible
that's incredible he's the richest
person at the Federal Reserve it's it's
absolutely incredible though here's what
I think should happen they should have
to show us their trading accounts what
has drawn Powell been doing in his
trading account bro
they're from their front running
everything I mean people have already
gotten caught with that they need to
learn whenever there's people work yeah
it's like the hardest thing to prove
though insider information trades yeah
I'm not even accusing them okay I am I'm
not even saying that what they did is
illegal right because there's all kinds
of things like matt levine from
bloomberg wrote a really great piece
around I think was Matt there so there's
an L train in in New York they all goes
from basically lower Manhattan
across to to Brooklyn and at one point
there was a very heavy discussion not
even rumors like actual public hearings
etc they were gonna shut down the El
train so people started moving out of
certain parts of Brooklyn because they
were like I'm not gonna be able to get
to work because there's no other train
other than the El train and the plan
that the city had was they were gonna
use buses to go across the bridge rather
than go in the subway
which would have been a nightmare and so
all of a sudden everyone starts leaving
what happens to real-estate prices they
all start sinking right to account for
that demand change well at some point
the city decided they weren't gonna shut
down the El train instead they were just
gonna make the changes at night when
nobody was riding the train and so I
guarantee you that there was people who
was aware of that decision before it was
announced when and started buying real
estate is that insider trading yes the
law no come right but is it ethical
I don't know right like it's a it's a
very complex situation so I'm not
accusing anybody of doing anything
illegal but what I am saying is take for
example somebody like cuddler right this
guy who keeps going he's like the
National economic director or whatever
after the frozen head talk-show host
maybe I don't know but a would Larry
Kudlow oh yeah a week into the economic
downturn they literally he went on
television and said now's a good time
for people to buy people should buy the
dip right and a week later he went on
and they were like you told people last
week to buy the dip but it's still
falling like what do you have to say for
yourself he said oh no I only said the
bite if you're a long-term investor but
like if he comes out but he's telling
people to buy but he's actually selling
in his personal port failure human but
there's the transparency thing that I
think you know whether you're whether
you're legally obligated to be
transparent or like you feel a moral a a
moral imperative to be transparent
that's kind of it be transparent is that
what you're asking Larry Kudlow to show
is his stock trades all of them Larry
Kudlow Jerome Powell the president
how about minuchin yeah man I'd love to
see him that is rolling by the way can
we talk about
one of the best photos ever is him and
his wife holding up the sheet of dollars
squirrel them like it literally looks
like out of a movie it's wild I mean
she's got like Louboutins Louis Vuitton
bag and you know did you did you read
when he said that the average US family
could live off of $1,200 for ten weeks
yeah he's smoking crack five blocks left
five blocks left we hit 80 170 think is
gonna do we see below 8k I don't know
man it bounced hard off of 81 70 and
went back to 84 53 but good sub 8,000
sub 1/2 that would be why sitting over
there on the couch and she just looks up
from her computer and goes dead cat
bounce I love it I love it today she got
an education on what a dead cat bounce
was and she was very confused when I
said no like a dead cat would bounce off
the ground and she said okay I don't
like this anymore so I mean how are
things in New York right now are people
still like lock down from Kovan these
guys getting back to work restaurants
opening I mean what's the story no
listen
here's my whole perspective on Kovan
missus uh everyone get their popcorn
ready because this I know this is a hot
take but I truly believe this Andrew
Cuomo and Bill de Blasio are complete
idiots like just flat-out idiots and
here's why they know what they're doing
and it's all political posturing so
here's what's going on in New York City
New York City is reporting I don't know
I'd have to look at the latest stats but
I feel like 15,000 deaths right from
kovat and they're yelling and screaming
about it's so bad to carry out this
whole thing I think kovetz real I think
it's killing people I think that we
should do a lot of things to address the
issue but the problem is they also have
their health people going out and here's
what they're saying at public press
conferences we're counting people in the
death row are eight that don't have
kovin do you say wait what do you mean
and so literally let's say 15,000 people
I remember the numbers at 12,000 right
so it was 12,000 people 7,000 people had
died from kovat right they tested
positive for COBIT and died now as part
of that it brings into the questions do
they die from kovat or did they
complications no complications yeah well
do they have a heart attack but we're
kovat positive and they get counted for
Kovac right they didn't decipher the
difference the other five thousand
people died never tested positive and
they were getting counted right right
but pomp again and I most people don't
know this but I was the medical examiner
of Cumberland County back in like 2010
through 2013 and that that position was
an appointment from the chief medical
officers space in Chapel Hill so the
office of chief medical examiner
appoints medical examiner's in each
County and I would be responsible for
forensics and assigning and signing the
death certificate on any homicide
suicide accidental death or death in the
hospital and oftentimes I wouldn't do a
full autopsy on those patients I would
take their medical history I would do a
superficial exam you know to toxicology
etc but I would have to figure out like
what was the cause of death and you know
it's all it would take was someone to
tell me that if anyone comes in with a
you know concomitant health problems so
cardiac issues diabetes respiratory
issues and that had a high fever
respiratory distress and died it would
be easy for me to correlate or establish
that they could have died through
complications of Cova 19 if I didn't
have a test so I just don't think it's
that big of a stretch now you can't say
everybody is dying from Kovac but I can
see how they could you know give some
guidance there here's the difference
though so there's a couple of key pieces
the stimulus bill you get paid for
saying they died from Kovac so the
financial incentive immediately switches
Hospital there's a possible hospital
gets money I think it's like I think
it's seven or eight thousand
dollars for every Kubik death so if
you're under financial pressure at the
hospital immediately now if I basically
if I say they died from Kovac whose
financial incentive the scar there's a
massive step up in payment if they were
on a ventilator no later right and it's
like twenty or thirty thousand dollars
so now it becomes a financial thing
which isn't great but the bigger problem
is and I kept saying this the data is
wrong I actually don't know is it better
or worse than what they're telling us
but they actively know that the data is
inaccurate and the problem is they just
go to the biggest number they can find
because it's all about headlines right
it's all about how do I get political
posturing right and look there's not a
person who's asked Andrew Cuomo a hard
question with the first three questions
I'd asked Andrew Cuomo in a press
conference one why are you still taking
a salary why you've taken away the
earning income of all the small business
owners in your state yikes right like
you're not a leader you're asking them
to do something you're not willing to do
second why did your brother supposedly
claimed that he had Kovac go off air but
then he was caught in the Hamptons at
the beach why are you going after his
brother's son because I don't believe
them you talk about that guy bike ride
Chris Como Chris Cuomo said he had Kovan
and then literally somebody stopped him
at a in the Hamptons with his family so
no didn't you say you had coolant didn't
you get in a fight with the guy that's a
I think that's it different that was a
difference no no I think he did I think
he customization oh I think he got in a
confrontation with that guy it's clown
town right the third thing I would ask
them is is Andrew Cuomo are you willing
to admit that or are you willing to
return any money from hospitals in your
state if it comes out later that the
person didn't die from Kovac
no of course not and by the way I don't
think that he should have to do that but
the point goes to it's getting them to
admit there's a huge financial incentive
here right and the sad part is that we
have to address both issues like the
debt but did it but what about beyond
the financial incentive what about the
political brinksmanship on top of that
so I you know isn't there kind of this
kind of Republican Democrat thing going
on when it comes to kovat as well there
seems like there's a lot of like pull it
you know push and tug and all that other
stuff going on with the president I mean
it's really sad actually but okay and
here's the
that part right is the people who get
caught in the middle or the people who
are actually suffering from the health
crisis and the people suffering from the
economic crisis so right now we have
states like you know all over basically
the the Midwest and the south and stuff
that are starting to reopen in various
stages New York City just extended their
shelter in place to June 6th so we got a
whole nother month of shelter in place
right but what ends up happening is
there it doesn't have to be so binary
but the reason why they want it to be
binary is cuz the shock and awe factor
it gives them control right like here's
the crazy part ready this goes directly
to like the bit Bitcoin ethos Bill
DeBlasio came out and said he is
outlawing protests right that literally
there's people protesting they have
masks on their social distancing there
they're protesting against him and what
he's doing and he said I'm gonna use the
military or the police force I have
they've men with guns and government
uniforms and we're not gonna let you
protest let me ask you this question and
you know we haven't we haven't prep for
this so when 9/11 happened and they hit
the Twin Towers
we got war and we got the Patriot Act
and from my perspective what the Patriot
Act
Patriot Act allowed the u.s. to do was
to establish that any bank in the world
doing business with who the United
States deems a terrorist they could slam
the door on them actually shut down
their banks and the Patriot Act exists
now you've got a AML kyc all the other
stuff associated with the Patriot Act
travel restrictions etc what what what
do we get from this what do we get from
the pan 2012 20 pandemic something's
happening yeah is it tracking trace is
it tracking trace so first of all it's
it's it is the right question is like
that this is the multi trillion dollar
question right what is the impact of all
of this coming out there will be more
surveillance there will definitely be
more kind of physical measures in place
here's the thing that scares me I
generally think that electronic
surveillance is going to continue not
because I want it to but that's just the
nature of technology that's the nature
of
it's all that kind of stuff people have
the ability to opt out but there's a
trade-off between convenience and
privacy so if you don't want somebody to
track you electronically don't use a
computer don't use a phone your life
will suck right to be almost impossible
to operate in today's society but you
can do that and not be tracked in that
manner and so obviously if that's not
possible then what's the next degree you
can kind of work your way to that
intersection of convenience and privacy
and where you're comfortable you just
gotta educate yourself the thing that
actually scares me more than that though
is that people complied and what I mean
by that is what happens next time with
like oh my god a virus is coming
everyone get inside
don't leave your home and frankly here's
the truth and don't don't organize and
protest right it spits beyond just stay
in your house no but look I'm not a
medical UC yeah did you see them arrest
the Australian woman with her child I
mean it was heartbreaking to watch I I
really struggled with that she was it
was a peaceful protest police organized
around her obviously she had broken some
local ordinance or law but it was
aggressive they ripped her child from
her it was really these are low points
in my opinion regardless of the law
being broken it just seems like we're
losing humanity we're losing civil
rights it's a little it's a distressing
it's distressing to see with just the
limited information I have yeah and
here's the beauty of it right the
research is distressing is Bitcoin
dropping to 8400 well the reason why I I
think so much about this other stuff is
I do believe that Bitcoin is getting to
be the size and and definitely the next
18 months we'll get to the size where
these macro events will have a material
impact right there there will be you
know things you have to consider and
understand the macro environment but at
the same time the beauty of Bitcoin is
that there's none of this there's none
of this politics there's none of this
kind of you know 13 people at OPEC go
into a back room and decide what to do
there's none of the you know Bank of
England governors get together for
dinner and make a monetary policy
decision yeah but don't let me let me
challenge that for a second because I
don't block the trolls and the
hit me constantly and we have these kind
of discussions and I try to learn you
know people people who hit me up will
say you know miners are doing this or
there's a there's a group that's
actually still engineering Bitcoin I
mean what do you say about about these
statements that bitcoins highly
manipulated the exchanges have all kinds
of wash trading going on there are
engineers involved in Bitcoin and at the
very end of this China is in control of
all the hash anyway and so they can
manipulate this thing seize seize the
day what do you think about all that
yeah I mean look it goes back to what's
being manipulated right the price being
manipulated on an exchange the value of
bitcoins not being manipulated the u.s.
dollar exchange price is being
manipulated by the way the Federal
Reserve is manipulated in the US dollar
price of Bitcoin why by devaluing the
dollar right so literally the Federal
Reserve is making Bitcoin more valuable
in USD terms every single year right now
we don't say hey the Federal Reserve is
manipulating the price because they're
doing it slowly over a long period of
time but they are manipulating the price
intentionally right and they're doing
that for lots of assets what doesn't get
manipulated is the core value prop of
Bitcoin which is that no one can
manipulate the monetary policy right and
the more that I've studied this and
spent time talking to people and really
thought critically about what is
bitcoins value proposition it has
nothing to do with technology right
because guess what you and I can go
create a Bitcoin tomorrow that matches
from a pair you know from a feature
parity standpoint it is the social and
psychological elements of Bitcoin
Bitcoin was able to capture the belief
of money and ultimately that's what
money comes down to you're right money
is a belief system and the reason why
the dollar has value is because we all
believe it does when I hand it to you
you think it's valuable I think it's
valuable right and actually the value
fluctuates today the dollar you and I
believe is stronger than it was six
weeks ago
that's why asset prices all fell and
everyone wanted dollars right the the
demand for dollars went up but what ends
up not being manipulated is no one's
gonna step in and say we're gonna print
more Bitcoin we're actually going to
accelerate
the having its right or any of us up
it's very programmatic it's very
transparent now if something was to
happen we would know immediately and on
top of that because of that transparent
programmatic nature people have bought
into the belief of money and what I
always tell the detractors is like let's
say you're right the Bitcoin has no
value that bitcoin is worthless all the
stuff the problem is you're on the wrong
side of the trade because the market has
disagreed with you for 11 years and so
if you only want to trade an asset how
long can you withstand being on the
wrong side of the trade and not change
your mind right and part of that is
you're actually getting more and more
pain as the longer you wait right so the
good news is you're not gonna lose money
it's not like you're shorting Bitcoin if
you're a detractor but you are missing
the opportunity set right or you're
missing the opportunity cost is what
you're giving up and so to me it's just
like I kind of just have stopped trying
to convince people right it's like a
thing of hey either you you take the
time and are self-interested enough to
go learn and understand the stuff or
you're not you know I was recently
watched you interview Robert Kiyosaki
but I was actually more interested in
him interviewing you I think he recently
went on his his podcast and I can't
remember the other fellow you went on
but he was like a gold expert or a Gold
Bug and Robert Kiyosaki
is an interesting person to say the
least but he does support
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin in particular I
think he owns some aetherium and some
other some other coins but he's big gold
and silver guy and it seems like you
support gold like you you're kind of you
you would hang with Peter Schiff and
have a beer I think you probably agree
with a lot of the things that he says
outside of his kind of you know venomous
BS about Bitcoin but you know cuz and I
said to you before like like I own gold
and I own silver I think they're really
interesting I've owned them for a very
very long time even as a little kid I
collected like proof sets and silver you
know but you know to have it
it's difficult like if you ever move
you've got bags of silver or bars of
gold it's kind of just clunking and it
really shows why bitcoins interesting in
terms of you know just that the the
ability to transfer it but what do you
think about gold and silver I mean do
you own any and like I own none but I
think that they're gonna do well right
like again it all goes back to the same
thesis or kind of the trend right and
that trend is the dollar is going to be
devalued over time it's probably going
to be accelerated because of all the
money printing and so any sort of store
value or inflation hedge assets gonna do
well real estate will do well Bitcoin
will do well gold and silver will do
well and then it just becomes a question
of like well what's going to do the best
out of all of us right and I think then
that's what you know seeing Paul Tudor
Jones basically come in and validate the
idea of I think he'd the way he phrased
it was like the fastest horse wins and
Bitcoin has that volatility and so you
know one of the things that you know you
know this because you and I talk about
all the time but I want the volatility
because the volatility works in both
directions yeah there's huge draw downs
but if you can stomach those it also
means that there's these massive upward
movements as well right and so that
volatility I would become much less
interested in Bitcoin if there wasn't
the volatility because that meant it
probably wouldn't have the volatility
needed to gain the market share and
eventually become a global reserve
currency right it's like it's amazing to
hear you say that because I recently
posted an interview that you did you're
on squawk box I think it was like
November 2018 and Bitcoin had gotten
down to like the mid three thousands and
I think Becky quick or Andrew Ross
Sorkin had said to you like are you are
you have you been buying or are you
buying this and you were like I'm buying
it all the way down and if that's so
counterintuitive most investors would be
like guy you're trying to catch a
falling knife but but your conviction is
that this thing's not going to zero if
it goes to zero it's all it's over
anyway essentially it's not going to go
to zero and even if it does it doesn't
necessarily mean it's over because we
saw oil go to minus 37
it's not over for fossil fuels so you've
got to develop that why won't go to zero
is again because of the belief system
you won't get every single person to
give up it may go to sub $1 right I
don't think but like from a structure
standpoint it could go really really low
but it won't go to zero because you'll
never come into every single person in
the world to walk away yep that's the
only way that you get in this type of
market that's only way you get a zero I
can actually you know $0.00 type thing
but I mean look again it's it's a it is
speculative in nature because of the
binary outcome
it's either worth way more than it is
today or it's worth way less there's no
10 years from now
bitcoins not worth eighty three hundred
dollars eighty four hundred dollars no
way
I you know what Wendy when do you think
it's materially worth more than eighty
four hundred dollars which it is right
now all right look I you know I've been
saying it for a while in the next 18
months by the end of 2021
December of 2021 I think we see at least
a hundred thousand dollar USD right so
the stock to flow model the original
stock to flow model showed a Bitcoin
price between 2020 and 2024 of fifty six
thousand dollars I think that was Plan
B's work and then this s 2 FX model is
revised that to two hundred eighty eight
thousand dollars yeah by the end of 2020
for now it doesn't mean it's gonna be
there it means it could have achieved
that that level which is unbelievable I
mean it's literally approaching the
market cap of gold at that point I think
288,000 old / Bitcoin is probably
somewhere depending on what numbers you
use and if you get a count for any lost
or destroyed Bitcoin it's probably in
the three hundred and fifty to five
hundred thousand dollar range on a
perfect coin again it's just to me like
I continue to say to people the Bitcoin
that I buy I hope one day literally my
grandkids grandkids grandkids right or
sit in there being like wow we'd had
this in the family for however long
because you have that type of time
horizon I don't care what happens to the
price right now right and you believe
that you'll book it like you look at it
like a store of value you'll look at it
like a unit of exchange you'll look at
it like an asset on your balance sheet
that you don't necessarily liquidate but
you could leverage against and just mark
it just like owning a house or owning
something that you're not selling every
year well just think about it I don't
know when it becomes a global reserve
currency I actually think we're probably
all well I think I think I think plan B
says phase 5 of bitcoins evolution it's
challenging for a global reserve
currency which is in my estimate
estimation and opinion pretty
mind-blowing and it's not a great
situation but anyway yeah I think that
Dad happens faster than we believe let's
say most people think it happens in 50
years right that's just a big brown
number way out there 50 years from that
happens I actually think whatever that
consensus number is it happens faster
because we underestimate what's possible
among you know the iPhone is 13 years
old some credible man well he's pretty
incredible if you think about that for a
second the iPhone this thing that we all
are like oh my god it's like a
supercomputer in our thing there unlike
that what the 11th or 12th iteration of
it yep it's got you know literally the
phone I have has three cameras it's
incredible and it's just like okay so
that can iterate so quickly I think that
we are likely under estimating one how
big Bitcoin can get into how fast that
can happen like if you had said the
people in 2009 who are on that
cypherpunk email list hey we think
bitcoins gonna be worth $10,000 in less
than 10 years right what ended up being
8 years is it hit $10,000 they would
have laughed at you
they've been like no way right but
that's what happened and so to me it is
it doesn't matter if it becomes the
global reserve currency today or in 50
years it is such a binary outcome that
that's where people have to get the risk
profile right like so many people talk
about the upside and the investment
decision I
keep talking about what is the risk
profile that you're willing to accept so
Paul Tudor Jones for example is one to
two percent right he says highly
suspected him I think it's gonna be the
best performer but it's unproven he's
super into managing his risks he's gonna
put one or two percent of his assets
well there's kids who are 20 years old
who are like dude do I buy the SNP do I
buy Bitcoin or do I hold cash well like
when you're 20 if I had to go back and
do it again me personally right I would
have risked every dollar I had because
it was nothing compared to what you're
gonna earn over your lifetime right and
so it's almost like you want to take as
much risk as possible the earlier you
are in life and understand them like
that means also that there's a higher
probability that you lose it all but I
pointing it didn't matter right now I
thought that you know whatever money I
had I was you know like oh my god I
can't lose this but in the grand scheme
of things actually you want to take as
much risk as possible it's interesting
that Bitcoin it about this like there's
probably three ways pretty direct ways
that you can gain wealth right you can
inherit it come up with an amazing idea
those ideas have idea babies and you're
the best in the world at executing on
that idea and you can monetize that and
then you just rinse and repeat it and
then finally if you have some assets
small even and you make a really super
focused outside investment like what
we're kind of talking about in Bitcoin
you can create some real wealth and
that's what you're saying right you're
saying it doesn't even take a lot of
money here you just have to have
conviction and you're making a choice
like do I buy a car at 20 or do I buy
Bitcoin you're saying I buy Bitcoin and
then I just hold it the cars a
depreciating asset Bitcoin could really
be something interesting and that's what
you're kind of saying right
absolutely it and it goes to this idea
that investing is not hard right like
Bill Perkins said this on on the podcast
the other day and I thought it was so
great that investing is a psychology
test and it's actually not a psychology
test again they've you overlaid that
with like a Warren Buffett or Charlie
Munger like actually we don't try to be
the smartest in the room we try not to
be stupid right and so if you think of
investing right now if I said to you
okay what's what are the keys to
financial success
there's
four things spend less than you make
have multiple strings of income put your
wealth into assets that can't be
inflated away right and then do things
that are high leverage in terms of your
not just trading your time for money
like those four rules if you follow them
and actually implement them you don't
have to be a genius and you'll be
incredibly wealthy but what ends up
happening is people literally who just
heard that will say what are those four
things mean so they don't know so I
gotta educate themselves too they then
say how do i implement them and then
three is it's boring like that's what
people don't realize is a lot of wealth
building is actually very boring it's
just about discipline and following
simple rules and so I tend to think that
that's where you know people struggle is
that it is so boring so check this out a
little housekeeping at the top of the
hour it looks like we have 29 minutes
until the having which is interesting
awesome to texting me saying that we
have more people in the live stream
right now would we have we got 2,500
people in here watching live and
supposedly finance
seesee I love you but by night only has
850 people in their live stream right
now now sees he's watching this I got
him right here
hey what's up cz I got you hey but can
you do me a favor and tweet the or which
I most them in the comments right now go
ahead yeah yeah I need I need you to
post the the Gemini lay knows I've been
posting it the whole time all right I'm
just making sure I'm just making sure
make sure you and there's a cool kind of
giveaway from block fly so if you'll
post that as well that would be cool and
I just want to make sure that we we are
in fact 28 minutes away so if people
that are out there watching this more
closely because I'm I'm literally
watching Bitcoin block half calm to get
to get a sense of when the reward drop
happens you give us like give us your
two minutes on block fine two minutes on
block fie yeah what are you making yeah
again if you're holding crypto assets
you could have them in cold wallets you
certainly shouldn't have them in a hot
wallet unless you're trading but if you
want to try to to gain some
interest on it so get your money to make
money and that that's part of the game
and creating wealth
I think block buys in a really great
option so it's a place that you can keep
some of your Bitcoin they have you know
operational security options that you
know are very good if not institutional
grade they've got insurance backing some
losses which is also good it gives you
some comfort and then if you're holding
cash and you have it in a money market
certainly a safe investment but if
you're willing to take on some more risk
now putting that cash into a stable
token electronic version or digital
digital token like G USD makes a lot of
sense and and for me you know I've said
this before I have some cash
I hold G USD I'm making a point six
percent APY on that that's a no-brainer
I came out of the stock market ten
months ago now punk yep you know ten
months ago I made given up some upside
but I didn't have to deal with this you
know economic crash it was out I thought
it was you know stock market had a lot
of zombie companies and the S&P seemed
like it was run up really high eleven
year bull run and so you know I
rebalanced everything and I'll tell you
it's given me a lot of comfort with all
that's happened shutting down startups
seeing people out of work you know for
me to have that eight point six percent
on my money has it was kind of luck but
also you know it feels good to have that
so anyway I think block-wise did a
really really good option I haven't used
their lending feature yet but I think
they're doing 50% LTV loans so if you
don't want to sell your crypto and you
want to take a loan you know again that
options there I think you're approved
rather quickly it's all done
electronically so check it out
absolutely and then I see multiple
people asking other options than
coinbase
Gemini here's my whole picture on Gemini
Bay and by the way we're investors in
coinbase
yeah look I just think that you can't
have a product go down and I got yeah I
mean I'm not gonna shell or endorse
something we got money and coinbase a
lot of money and I don't use it yeah and
it's just at the end of the day what you
end up seeing is you got me and let's
figure it out coinbase so I think that
Gemini the whole point here is they
basically have a product where it is the
most important thing in the market is to
have trust right Trust is the product
and what does that mean that means you
don't go down that means that you
constantly have liquidity and it means
that you have security right and I think
that they were one of the first people
to understand the way that you build
trust is you have all the sock audits on
the security side and you say look you
know they had a whole campaign around
crypto needs rules right and and there's
two ways to look at that there's plenty
of people who say you know we should
have full sovereignty
there should be no KY caml you know all
these different things and there's an
element you know even I agree with that
but at the same time that unfortunately
is not the rules of today right the
financial system rules are that they
have to have that stuff and so I think
that what Gemini has been able to do in
terms of you know providing a very safe
environment for people is incredibly
important and they've kind of done
things the right way
right if you think about it from they've
been around a long time they have not
rushed to add every asset in the world
they only recently started to add so yes
some other assets there but trust is the
product right and I think that's really
compelling and then the other thing that
we should say is so we're investors in
in block fly obviously big fans we use
Gemini as well and then block find
Gemini have a partnership right we're
actually all of the block fly crypto is
stored with Gemini so Gemini is
providing the custody there and so
there's a lot of trust between those two
companies I think as well definitely
all right listen there's tons of
questions coming in I know you guys have
all been asking I've been ignoring you
on purpose but I'm gonna run through and
we're gonna try to answer as many of
these as we can let's see here pop what
is your preferred mobile wallet are
there any good ones Jason is the expert
the in-house expert what would you say
is the best mobile wallet I used to
trust wallet trust wallet that's owned
by my Nance right yeah I think it's
really cool I think you know I also have
messed around finance decks so you might
want to check that out but trust wallet
is good all right Jason's handlebar
goatee is winning this stream Eric we
hear you man we definitely hear you know
folk rats thank you yeah they said 3%
alcohol got you hyped up I haven't even
finished 1/3 of that beer I'm always
high what do we think of investing in
uranium mining what do you think about
that I haven't thought of it there you
go I'll think about it
so uranium and lithium there's a whole
bunch of reasons as to why those are
going to be valuable I have no clue
about the prospects of mining it fat
battery tech and nuclear weapons yeah
well not only nuclear weapons but also I
think isn't uranium mining used for
nuclear power yeah but I'm saying
nuclear and battery tech yeah I will say
I had mark Schneider come on he was a
former nuclear engineer in the Navy he
came on and gave me like a 101 course on
the podcast around nuclear power I was
blown away by how much I didn't
understand it and also how many
preconceived notions I had that were
inaccurate bro we're living we're living
a we're living a lie America makes so
much power like so much power we just
don't we don't turn it on like well you
know a certain portion of the world's in
the dark for no reason we could turn the
lights on in the world and probably not
even use fossil fuels but yeah keep
going yeah it just it makes no no sense
are we looking at the clock yes we're
watching the clock 22 minutes the
percentage on block 5 for Bitcoin
interest I think is 6% right now rabbits
but it's a certain number of Bitcoin is
it less than five yeah it changes and it
drops yeah and then I think less than
five it drops say to two and change
percent above five whoa
here's a great question DCA or lump sum
if you have money that you want to
deploy how do you think about either
deploying all of it at once or
dollar-cost averaging you go so if you
had asked me this question six months
ago I would have told you DCA into an
asset like Bitcoin just because there's
so much volatility I recently read
something I believe it's dollars in data
I think Nick wrote it and he talks all
about should you lump sum or should you
dollar cost average and he had a bunch
of math in there that made it very
compelling argument as to why you should
do a lump sum the only thing that I will
say is I think that that lump sum type
investment makes a lot of sense for an
asset that is not nearly as volatile as
Bitcoin I dollar cost average we dollar
cost average in our funds Jason dollar
cost average is I tend to think that
when you have a highly volatile asset
that's the best way to go I agree you
agree
I mean look having having the discipline
to have your debt-to-income ratios in a
situation that you have cash or you have
a stable token that you convert to
Bitcoin you know that that is a strategy
you know of itself and that's that's
what I'm using I'm sitting there with
cash and stable tokens and just taking
positions as I go yeah people are asking
about wise block find not in New York so
for those that don't know New York State
has your license no financial services
they've got something what the hell is a
calmer to forget the bit like yeah the
money transfer license or bit license
bit license it's basically a special
license that you need you have to apply
and get it from the DFS in in New York
they've only given out 30 of them or so
so far but I definitely think that
they'll get it at some point
process and once they get it they'll be
able to go ahead and offer in New York
Bitcoin mining they want to know about
mining you want to talk about all about
a PRT I in mining yeah so you know a PRT
I we take trash tires and we get paid
per pound for these trash tires that
would normally be thrown out in a
landfill or or chopped up and used as
like rubberized surfaces or pellets or a
soccer field and we break them down into
constituent parts that they're made so
the tires got synthetic gas oil it's got
carbon black it's got steel it's got
Kevlar and fabric in it when you heat it
to a certain temperature it goes from a
semi solid to a gas vapor you can take
that vapor stream and you can condense
it into a liquid fuel that's combustible
you get a synthetic gas that you can
combust as well and then you're left
with carbon it it can be burned at like
10,000 BTU which is like a mid grade
Appalachian coal you can load that all
into some combustion situation and
create steam or energy and what we do
with power that we make at PRT is we
mind
Bitcoin and aetherium specifically
aetherium which EP use and mining is is
the backbone of of these networks so
every 10 minutes gosh twelve and a half
Bitcoin are awarded to the network and
if you contribute hash which is
essentially taking those computers that
are specifically made to do this
computation backed by power you compete
for your portion of those block rewards
and you know Bitcoin can be very
profitable if you do it the right way
mining can be very profitable if you if
you set up correctly they're asking why
we say don't buy Bitcoin or crypto with
your credit card that's just well why
don't you why don't you go and then I'll
go
just super volatile you're using
somebody else's money to buy an asset
that may or may not have the same value
in the future and so I don't think you
want to use money that you're paying in
many cases you know 18 to 24 percent on
that's to buy an asset that could drop
in value but that's my point it's a if
you're using leverage that's just very
it's very expensive leverage when you're
doing a real estate transaction and
usually leverage
I mean we're negotiating after putting
20% down on on a real estate project
somewhere between 2.75 and three point
two five percent right I'm willing to
take leverage at that point because I
can service the debt
the problem is with Bitcoin you can at
18% with you know it's highly volatile
and you could be in a really tough
situation if you can't service the debt
yeah
there's a bunch of questions all asking
or hold on about the ETFs the gbtc and
retirement accounts how do you think
about that you know early on and still
may be the case you know if you if you
had an IRA and you wanted to get some
exposure to Bitcoin gbtc was your only
option so you know I I own gbtc and full
disclosure and I paid a lot for it it's
expensive I don't know if it still has
the premium it did when I bought it but
it had a 25% 30% premium on it I don't
know what it is now do you know that
offhand pop I think is around 10% but is
a drop teaching I dropped yeah so it
dropped but yeah so if you want some
exposure and and you're able to do it
you can you can transfer you could buy
gbtc through your Roth IRA a hundred
percent of my retirement account is in
gbtc mine too I mean look it's the
retirement accounts for somebody my age
right I can't get it for 30 years
it's such a binary outcome right it
sounds some people are saying the
premium was 30% on Friday I don't know
if that's right yeah so it was 30% when
I did this back in
percent today they're saying all right
but back in I think it was like 2017
something like that 2017 2018
I went all in on gbtc but I was paying a
30% premium it was before it's split so
I don't know when it split either does
anyone know that offhand I do not know
let's see here what else uh bitcoins 84
64 so it's bouncing around that range
still and we got right somewhere right a
room there thinks oh man I think it's
this is this is it it's 15 minutes man
all right so a couple of things more
housekeeping one if you're watching this
right now that says 2,600 people on here
I would love to get to 3,000 at some
point please hit the like button so that
more people on YouTube see it go tweet
the link do whatever you want but help
us get to 3,000 simply because then I
can go and tell everyone that we had
more people on our stream that anybody
else we should just be a nice flex for
the Internet to anybody watch that crack
in a VR thing that was pretty cool
I think people did yeah it was pretty
cool I saw Travis clang he's a boss we
have music join our team he's on our
team son Travis clang we have two blocks
to go maybe when having a curves will
have Polina come over here and say hello
she's shaking her head no saying don't
use me as a pawn maybe we'll have her
come over here prop and if you like the
oh wow a bunch of you just like the
video you guys are awesome we appreciate
it make sure you subscribe to the
channel as well so you can get
notifications when we do this more there
are two blocks left here's my two
questions for you as we wait out the
next 20 minutes or so one what would
have to change for Bitcoin what would
have to change in the Bitcoin
environment for you to change your mind
and think that we do not have our
bitcoins not the future like what would
have to change
by the way while you're thinking I'll
buy you some time while you're eating
and thinking cuz you're on mute right
now somebody just texted me and said
we're number two Oh Joe cloak is just
texted me Joe what up way to get this
hooked up we're number two on youtubes
auto-generated live channel for
technology can we get to number one Joe
if it happens screenshot it let's see
polenta immediately asked who's number
one Peter Shiff now the corona the the
Roy lab stats corona virus pandemic
real-time counter oh come on man we
can't be around a virus
come on we can beat corona virus come on
hey wait look you got to get a beer huh
you have to have a beer you've been
drinking water you're gonna kill me
yeah no beer right well I have one
better I have a sticker all right but
you have to have a drink you have to
have a glass of wine yeah so you gotta
get some gotta get something I will I'll
have a shot when it comes it comes
hardcore this was supposed to happen
tonight and I know chicken wings
I'm telling you things all right wait
what would have to happen for you to
change your mind on Bitcoin well I think
a hack a hack of the actual Bitcoin kind
of protocol not not something external
but actually you know something taking
down taking down the network you know
exposing some kind of flaw inside you
because people people try to claim that
there has been some type of issue with
the protocol historically but that
that's I think that could be devastating
to the whole the whole ecosystem I mean
what do you think I think a self-imposed
wound meaning that during the
development process a bug is introduced
and goes undiscovered if somebody
exploits it so so it's kind of like you
know there's some sort of technical
attack but it's actually through
something that is self-imposed by
accident yeah you know what else could
be really hard for Bitcoin is if if ASIC
miners become illegal to bring into the
United States due to you know just
paranoia and conspiracy
see theories about backdoors and and
china building this computing you know
force in the united states i think that
could be really that could potentially
hurt bitcoin as well do I wonder how
many nation states would follow our lead
uh uh it's getting real it's getting
real
Hellena by the way is giving me the most
disproving look in the world why is that
she said it's 4:00 p.m. I said actually
she doesn't know is only three fifteen
all right second question for you who do
you think Satoshi is hmm well it's not
Craig right right I agree
okay it's not Craig right and I recently
put a poll up that said it could be
Peter Schiff but that was a joke it's
not Peter Schiff and the poll actually
said Adam ami was Satoshi kind of
edamame who's that it's like a soy-based
protein that you eat oh the thing that
you get with sushi well you can't get it
with sushi have you ever had a domani
I think it's edamame right oh don't even
try it
edamame yeah at a moment it may be
edamame but it won out of the poll
edamame beat Peter Schiff and Craig
Wright as Satoshi
well they it probably has a better
chance of being Satoshi than either one
of those I think Satoshi was a think
tank a think tank yeah I think it was a
group I think oh she was a group of
people hmm
I don't think it was one person why oh
[Music]
you want to know who's on the stream who
Peter safe Joe Lorenzo hey Uncle Joe
what's up out on the Giro fireman from
New York City Joe taught me everything I
know about investing everyone go find
Joe Lorenzo in the comments
shout out to Uncle Joe
I think it could have been a think-tank
man like this the way DARPA works and
the way the way you know I don't know if
you guys saw that like lazar thing about
area 51 I think it's like spaceships and
an area 51 on Netflix all of this stuff
like blows my mind
like when you see stealth technology was
like invented in 1974 and when we
started the war in Iraq they were like
spaceships that you couldn't detect on
radar flying around and you know that's
like twenty-year-old tech now because
we're so numb to news like the the
Pentagon confirms yeah they're UFOs
nobody even cares you know it's snowing
in May in New York says nobody says
anything about that like I don't know
what's going on man
so could Satoshi be a think-tank yes a
group locked down like area 51 only to
be known what 40 years from now or
whenever they they release that
information that's my thing or it could
have been one person who's dead listen
we got about one block to go we got 200
290 people watching this thing and take
that shot
we need unless when the having habits
were taking shots I'd like everyone to
go and like the video go tweet it do
whatever get us to 3,500 people away
from 3,000 concurrent hey I got eight
minutes eight minutes for what to have
it yeah look we're good to go minutes
eight minutes I got to cow break the
roll is that a full shot do here's what
I want to see in the comments yes or no
should we make plan to come over here
and say hello I want Polina to take a
shot take a shot on camera for the
having are we going 2920 are we gonna
get Polina on the livestream before the
halving and are we all gonna take a shot
or not let's roll baby
and bitcoins holding its 85 24 on the
1-hour I mean what does it look like on
the four-hour chart Jared Thompson I see
you with the rum and coke now
getting people telling us what they're
drinking all right get him up get him up
Wow I'm gonna asked about Polina there
the I can't keep up with the comments
it's just yes come on Polly 9 all right
yeah come on over yeah we're all right
it's time to ask Polina some questions
somebody said you should do a body shot
off my Bitcoin belly here oh 2975 we're
so close all right
are you coming in here seven minutes
seven minutes
Hey here she is all right you got to
introduce her the people want to know
wait wait wait wait wait wait before you
do that you gotta introduce her like you
do on lunch money oh the beautiful and
intelligent plain tamara nova wearing
today her skiing outfit ready to go
snowing in New York all right
oh we're so close to 3,000 so close mm
994 did you bring a bunch of people with
you yeah that's where he always does
what we're looking over here 3,000 there
we go
let's go that's fine all right what do
you have to say the people about Bitcoin
what is Bitcoin Bitcoin it's an
asymmetric non-correlated assets how
many bitcoins total are there 21 million
what's happening today what's the having
but how many are there gonna be
after the having every day no 800 closed
80 no you get like a you get like a
b-plus on the kid I doing good doing
good all right they're all saying their
lunch money fans Oh Saxena
she learns she's gorgeous she's a cougar
bang bang lol Polina take a shot
should we all take a shot together Elena
this is a big event it's like the
Olympics I don't okay here's here's told
to make question same question I asked
Jason he thinks the two she is it's a
woman why because there is not a man in
history that would be able to keep his
ego right to have all this come out like
we have to take a left
course I invented the woman that is the
hot take of all hot takes I love it no
why don't you get a chair and sit down
get a drink drink yeah oh yeah there
akia that's a Bulgarian liqueur
I can't they they love Bulgarian liquor
can you move this are you taking over
yeah okay Bulgarian liquor clear or
brown it's basically just really super
strong liquor really really super strong
liquor but it's made from grapes yes
kind or greens okay interesting so it's
not like moonshine because like
moonshine okay it's like who's Oh
interesting
hey guys big big day today though I got
pants on I'm not wearing sweat pants
shorts needs to see them every single
day I've been wearing sweat pants shorts
alright we're good to go are we ready
for this we're probably one block away
from the habit four minutes four minutes
or there's two nads
alright 3000 170 people Wow
lots of Bulgarians in the comments of
course what are we doing in your house I
don't think we're in your house Jason's
in his own house
eighty eighty five sixty eighty five
sixty oh we got people from Turkey how
about this I want every single person to
leave a comment right now where you're
tuning in from and I'll read them out
Oh what what city state or country are
you coming from let's see if we can do
this real quick blue tie when we put the
blue tie on oh there you go there's the
having it just halved
I believe that having just occurred
bang-bang having to everyone shot cheers
that's for everybody no you don't want
any no no happy happy
did it happen I think it just happened
who Bulgarians said three minutes
Netherlands Sweden Germany Long Island
UK England Australia Colorado Boston
London San Francisco Florida Rochester
Kansas City Norway Costa Rica Poland
Cincinnati Los Angeles Italy holy [ __ ] I
can't keep up Sommerfeld London Florida
Chicago Minnesota London London ATL
Ethiopia Japan Italy South Africa
Melbourne hey it's coinbase working what
is coinbase working all right real quick
why everyone's still paying attention
quick housekeeping items one like the
video to subscribe 3 there's two
sponsors the first is Gemini Gemini
provides awesome institutional crypto
currency exchange and custody go I'll
post it in the comments go check them
out sign up for an account by Krypto
their store crypto there if you want as
well to block Phi you can give them
crypto they'll give you a US dollar loan
or you can give them crypto they'll pay
you a very high interest rate up to
eight point six percent APY in an
interest-bearing account on your crypto
Jason and I are both users and big fans
of both of those companies so please go
check them out they've been awesome and
helping us put this together and it
would mean a ton to us and to them if
you guys go ahead and check all of that
out and download their their new apps
yes they both have new mobile apps
Gemini's not new but it's good and
block-wise is new and it's good to dude
I can't keep up there's people still
leaving all the places that they're from
Northern Ireland Holt Holland is
credible alex ernst said Polina get
money get paid are you starting a
movement without money get paid wait
Jason I made this well no it sounds like
she joined like bad boys it's like a
relic she's part of like a crew is that
like she's showing Weezy get money get
paid so here's the story behind get
money get paid one day we're sitting on
the couch I'm just watching some video
on my computer and she just looks over
at me and I look at her like can I help
you and she hits me with get money get
paid and husband what what and she was I
don't know if skew my head I had to say
it Barcelona Halifax Nova Scotia
Colombia Dubai Azerbaijan yeah I think
that's where a mirage feel man there's
people from all over the world this [ __ ]
global everyone I love that yep I love
it alright what else well I'm actually
pretty surprised that bitcoins 8585 48
you know it really has done pretty much
nothing coming through the having here
and it held its value my $6,800 call was
wrong I never got to buy cheap Bitcoin
I'm a little disappointed but you know
it may not be over it may not be over
but man this is I wonder what's going on
in a lot of miners lines right now well
it the economics just got real difficult
potentially for a lot of people right
they're only making half as much money
yeah so maybe them what is what is the
hash freight look like right now
actually that could be interesting
blockchain calm has some analytics on
mining
I mean that may be interesting
all right I have no clue what it is
polina loves looking at the comments she
loves reading what people are talking
about yeah I literally can't keep
there's so many people commenting I
can't keep up what's up good so it looks
like it looks like we're at like a new
all-time high in terms of total hash
John which is odd dan said you know why
the price isn't going down no one is
selling food yeah that's true people are
telling us alright see you guys in four
years yeah its global so it looks like
there is 136 million Tara hash a second
right now there goes the price ooh
nether blood YouTube commenter plenty
look fully vested oh I was a good
comment that was a good one
oh here's another joke get jailed pointa
we all know you have it
thanks for the profile
polina is the people person Jason I
think that's a shot at us hey why don't
you pitch polina's cleanest work is
gonna pitch no no you got us you got a
pitch let's go short tank short tank
alright so I write something called the
profile which is a weekly newsletter and
it features the most interesting
long-form profiles audio clips videos on
successful people and companies I've got
I got one question for you yeah if I
read this when is it how often is it
written you get smarter you'll get money
get paid is gonna cite if I read this
hole I get money get paid yeah alright
very good people are saying that plan is
rockin the pad Iguchi hide the little I
know you guys don't like brands on
movies Jason's got a black rifle shirt
on black rifle coffee oh it's a big
supporter
you know who black rifle Kong coffee
yeah but it's like I think actually yeah
don't know that veteran-owned
veteran-owned they're all like operators
that they got some really cool coffee
shops for for veterans and active duty
military sell good coffee I don't think
they do bulletproof coffee I have that's
what you're asking the one with butter
in it yeah
they may it's just regular coffee yeah
cool we should get some yeah a cup of
Jill for some Jose that's not a bad
motto not a bad one I don't think that's
their motto so now people are saying
that the motto for this stream is get
money get paid
that is true that is true alright so now
that we're through the having and he
actually successfully occurred what do
we think hey that's not a that's not a
just a kind of a not a big event that's
a big deal actually right
programmatically without a book like
nothing broke the world didn't end like
life's going on but something pretty
dramatic happened right so listen I
couldn't agree more interesting what
Paul Tudor Jones said in on CNBC is that
he said every day that goes by that
bitcoin doesn't break more trust is
earned right that's right
lyndie effectively Li ndy no look IIIi
think I actually said in a couple of
interviews over the last couple of
months I said look the first risk of
Bitcoin is that the having has to occur
if the having didn't just occur people
be freaking out if we got to that block
and having didn't execute it would have
been mass chaos because people would be
worried about what's wrong why didn't
the code execute it's not
programmatically doing what it's
supposed to do whatever so there's an
element of Bitcoin has to do what it's
intended to do in order to drive value
yeah right oh babe there we go it just
did what it's supposed to do
I already tweeted and I said bitcoins
third having successfully executed
bitcoins the most transparent
predictable monetary policy in the world
I like that it's so consistent and you
can trust it you know
it's true right yeah hey pop what do you
think about my statement that like
Satoshi was a genius because he created
this amazing marketing event that is the
having and people took shots at me for
that they're like nos a marketing what
do you think about that kind of that
thought I think that it's like it's a
chicken or egg thing right did he create
it because it's a marketing event or
doesn't become a marketing event because
it's part of the monetary policy I don't
know but I it's so hard to assign all of
the genius moments to one person because
think about what we're doing right now
essentially the world is watching an
algorithmic change to monetary policy
associated with Bitcoin that is
essentially an event it's like the
Olympics to me
even though Olympics got cancelled
because it canceled right your argument
is that the Bitcoin having didn't get
cancelled by the pandemic yeah yeah JC
you want to know what I'm tweeting right
now no no don't hit me with it hit me
with it
yo Peter Schiff Bitcoin has a lower
inflation rate than gold now just saying
uh uh shots fired
Maxo fired in fact though he was taken
lapse this morning did you see him yeah
listen I like Peter a lot you asked me
about him earlier the reason why I like
Peter Mladic's I actually think Peters
been really really right about a lot of
aspects of the financial system he
called the 2008-2009 crisis perfectly he
was starting to sound the alarm about
there being over levers in the system
exception now so I think that he is very
very intelligent I think that he's just
missing the last 10% of his analysis
which is great all of that is the
problem what are the assets that are
gonna do well I think he got gold right
but I think that he's missing Bitcoin in
that analysis and if he would just add
Bitcoin alongside gold doesn't replace
gold but the long side it then we would
be rocking and rolling and I think that
he would be a you know bonafide Bitcoin
her but it's hard for him to do that
because he just missed right he knew
about it so early he can't
buying Bitcoin at $8,500 when he knew
about it at $10 we've come across some
interesting characters I mean we we had
lunch with Dennis Cartman and I've been
personally blocked by Nouriel Roubini
I'm not yeah you have to and that that
was wild but I think he took a lap
recently as well with something that I
think was that the 15% drawdown that
happened like last night you know they
were all sputtering about how this thing
is going to zero yeah I mean look by the
way that's great but you know what ends
up happening right is at the end of the
day nobody cares what their opinion is
or frankly what your in my opinion is at
the end of the day the market decides
the winners and losers and the market
has decided that bitcoin has value it's
actually decided that bitcoin has a
hundred and seventy billion dollars of
value on a market cap basis and
regardless of what you me Peter Schiff
Nouriel Roubini or anybody else thinks
the markets gonna decide what the future
value is less about you and I being
right is more about us trying to fear
what does the market think in the coming
months and years
so I've got a question for you because
this is something I was really thinking
about post having if there wasn't if
there wasn't a like amazing kind of
unknown that happened post having it
looks like the price is stuck around
8500 let's just say is that the new
floor of Bitcoin um I don't know if it's
the new floor but I definitely think
that it is it is an important number
what I would say is the miners are gonna
determine the floor more than anybody
right because I was thinking the miners
would determine the number to be 6,800
is this the number is this the number I
did kind of my own back-of-the-envelope
analysis to try to determine what the
price to mine Bitcoin was you know
around the world taking it to event all
the information I had
and I felt like it was between 5,000 and
6,800 the best in class do it and could
be profitably cheaper some much higher
but I really felt like Bitcoin couldn't
exist at 3000 it would knock out most of
the hash rate yeah I think that it's um
it's this really weird thing of there
will be periodic dips below that rate
but like we saw most miners capitulate
when in December 2018 we dropped a 3k
right but not everyone capitulated 1 and
then 2 is there some miners who actually
mined at a negative price point because
they had believed he was going to
recover relatively quickly right and so
then when it came back they were mining
profitably right and then their
appreciation of the Bitcoin even though
it was a unit economic negative in the
short term over a long period of time it
ended up being a positive right but
check it out though like you had if you
if you go to your 4-hour chart and you
look at what just happened you had this
I don't know what happened on April 28th
I think we tried to unpack that right
but right around April 28th we were at
7600 the Bitcoin ripped all the way up
to 90 95 then he dropped back down to 88
and then it it hit 10,000 right so you
had this big pre having by the rumor
event in my opinion and I was expecting
it to sell the news and it kind of did
write a may 11th it sold the news down
to 8,000 so we lost $2,000 in value a
Bitcoin during that time period I
thought there would be a big minor
capitulation puke could that still be
coming it's possible I mean look there's
a bunch of miners who just ran into a
wall right the question is do they
capitulate immediately did they'll just
turn off their machines and the lagging
indicator will be will see hash rate
drop is there going to be over some
period of time let's say the next week
we see that or is it over
like a six to eight week period I think
every mm isn't it every 2016 blocks you
have a difficulty adjustment which is
about every two weeks right so two weeks
from now we will we will know will we
know or do we know now looking at hash
rate if there was a capitulation and a
hash rate drop because that that would
be correlated directly right yeah
if the Brit begs the question of does
hash tree indicate price like lead price
or his price lead pass rate I mean I
think that's interesting to think about
how do you determine the price of
Bitcoin like what what do you use as
metrics to try to determine the price if
you're doing doing research you want my
smartass answer I look at the chart and
I'll tell the market prices now I think
how do you determine what the future
price is gonna be is I don't worry about
it right like that's part I think that's
my advantage so I compete some ask me I
think was last week so what's your
advantage why do you participate in that
market why do you think you have an
advantage and I said well my greatest
advantage is that I actually have the
lowest time preference out of most of
the people in the market and therefore I
can have the most control psychology and
emotions and therefore I can allow the
you know to not do anything when
everyone else is either panicking on the
drops or FOMO and on the rises number
twenty seventeen though when you
panicked well that was on the way up
doubtful oh wait it was on the way up no
when I said it will go up cuz you were
like oh that was like three weeks ago
fifty per minute I was like whoa I live
I was sitting here like staring off into
space I I was sure it was contemplating
life yeah but those are some of my
favorite calls when he calls me it could
be like 4:00 in the morning 7 a.m. he's
like bro bro Wow why rather than do the
thing that my emotion said to do I did
the opposite and I bought I love that
man right and it's just like it
it's this deep-seated belief of like
I've done the work I have a thesis
nothing for the thesis has changed if
price drops that's actually a discount
that is not a change in value which is
really really hard to do when it drops
fifty percent you know one other piece
of advice for for people who are here in
this Bitcoin space it's really important
to have like a friend like a wingman yes
because it's so emotional there's so
many times that like pomp talks me off
the ledge you know I'm about to do
something dumb and I'm sure it's vice
versa but can't you find a wing man or
wing woman speaking of wing woman people
are asking pleated a scratch her head
twice if she needs to scratch your head
twice if she needs help do you need my
expertise or should I go
what expertise do you have to contribute
she actually knows way more about
Bitcoin than most people which is pretty
funny
who's the better cook and baking yeah
except we're not baking now because I
made sure girlis muffins the other day
but he claims what good are you serious
plan is a fantastic coated she's only
ever messed up two meals the first meal
she ever cooked where she made
dehydrated pasta which wasn't so great
was bad we got off to a bad start there
and then the second meal and the second
meal she messed up was like three days
ago when she hit us with some was it
sugarless muffins like cookies that's
good you know when you pick up a cookie
and it's kind of melting a little bit
you're like if you try with muffins you
won't have the same idea pizza right now
he's eating like to show people were
saying that your pizza looks great
it was actually pretty good and it's a
cauliflower based oh yeah it was good
how did you guys meet does that make it
better it makes it gluten-free oh people
are saying that you're trying to poison
you that's what oh you know I try to
poison me after the fact is that right
yeah all right let's we're gonna take
let's do till uh 355 we'll do nine more
minutes anybody who has questions send
them right now in the comments and I'll
fire them at Jason then we'll see what
we can answer for you guys how many how
many people did we have for you at the
at the height of this bomb
3100 people not bad yeah they said when
Polina came on the price of Bitcoin
jumped but you're drinking a miller lite
which isn't gluten-free they're giving
you [ __ ] that's right I don't have a
gluten intolerance if you keep asking
her what bitcoin is every podcast the
undercooked muffins will continue that's
fire
all right let's we're gonna give the
people what they want magic are you
ready are you ready for this
conversation they want to know what we
think of XRP there are you guys happy
we're gonna talk about XRP sure we're
happy to talk so okay can I say from my
experience yes yes Aloha
no basically what happened was I do I
want to get this phone do they it is a
safe story to tell people okay I curated
my Twitter that was really really nice
and then one time he tagged me in
something with XRP and then I got all
sorts of XRP people coming at me and I
didn't know army the army except the
army came after you don't know what do
they say to you well it was a lot of
like women with like not a lot of
clothes and what were they saying that
XRP army sounds like an interesting
group how was your experience yes I all
right Jason what do you think I don't
know I haven't had that same experience
I'll show you yeah no I think XRP is
interesting you know and I said this
recently on a podcast and I may be wrong
think to think of it this way but you
know when you don't by a token and or
work to generate that token and and it
gets dumped on people who are making
active investments on it
it just seems like something's wrong and
I know people say well we sell twelve
million dollars a Bitcoin a day or
something like that
that miners do but they they're actually
making investment to get that and when
XRP dumps on the xrp army it just seems
it seems really harsh am i directionally
incorrect with that or is that no I
think I think that's alright look I
literally think I believe that ripple
the software company which is building
software products for banks to make
their lives easier makes a ton of sense
I am not convinced that XRP makes sense
as part of that system and those two
things are separate and I think it's
important that people understand the
separation of them and you can have
ripple the company the software company
where you own equity succeed and XRP not
be successful I don't believe that you
can have XRP be successful without
ripple the software company being
successful right that's kind of how I
think about it and so like I'm not one
of these people who just blanket hey
nothing else has value but I try to be
somewhat on the intellectually honest
and think critically about the nuances
here and so that's how I break it down
it is ripple the software company is
different than XRP and I think that the
value of cruz to ripple the software
company i've got an interesting question
for you as you sort through kind of some
of the other questions what is your most
what is the the project or token you're
most interested in other than Bitcoin in
etherion oh man are you ready for this
hit me with it gift oh let me make sure
I could see Jace's face when I say not
it's our boy Jack Mahler's Oh
interesting
that's a Mike so there's a lot of people
asking about the Lightning Network we
haven't talked about it at all I think
that bitcoin is the most binary bet you
can make right now in finance I recently
tweeted and said on Wall Street it's a
contrarian bet but I think it'll become
a a consensus bet over the next two to
four years if you ask me inside of the
Bitcoin
community or inside a crypto I think the
single most important project outside of
Bitcoin itself is the Lightning Network
because it is that second layer that
helps Bitcoin scale and do a lot of
things I think that Jack Mahler's who
we've invested in zapping and in his app
strike is one of the most thoughtful
best builders in that ecosystem and if
he can accomplish half of what he wants
he will have done more than most to help
usher Bitcoin into becoming a global
reserve currency isn't he also really
good at chess oh you have a very good
memory he's actually a high school chess
champion that is true yep that's where I
use are you strike to feed the chickens
yeah business you chickens know I have
access to chickens that I feed remotely
through strike and the Lightning Network
watch yeah I know
mind blown you can check it out at polio
feed comm there's a video there's like a
live stream of chickens
yeah Bluetooth enabled device you can go
press a button you pay yeah you pay you
pay with some Bitcoin and drops chicken
feed and I feed yeah my favorite
chickens big black shut out big black
keep it real son get money get paid all
right Jason real quick before uh before
we let everyone go everyone's asking
I guess you tweeted and said you're
gonna do a giveaway what do you want to
give away no I already gave it away I
probably gave away Bitcoin oh you always
get people's Bitcoin but I haven't done
a giveaway in a while but yeah all right
all right guys listen go like the video
that little thumbs up go smash the [ __ ]
out of that make sure you're subscribed
to the channel so you get notifications
in the future when we do these maybe
we'll do a couple more lives change so
these are fun second of all there's two
sponsors for today Gemini and black five
black fire lets you deposit crypto you
can get take a u.s. dollar loan against
it or you can go ahead and earn up to
eight point six percent ap why they also
allow you to buy and sell Krypton
exchange Gemini is the most trustworthy
crypto exchange they've got a bunch of
sock audits on the security side trust
is their product they allow you to buy
and sell various crypto currencies
started by the Winklevoss twins who by
the way I don't Cameron any tighter on
here so I can say this I think I tweeted
this one time Cameron and Tyler
Winklevoss are going to go down as some
of the best investors ever in history
I actually think they've got a shot to
be one of the first trillionaires in the
entire world simply because of a massive
bet they made on Bitcoin many many years
ago bro if my maths not wrong
I mean if Bitcoin Bitcoin stays right
now or ten thousand dollars I think
they're worth like fifty-six like some
crazy I don't want to say it's some
crazy crazy number the crazy number what
do you think is the amount based on them
only 1% of the Bitcoin what does
bitcoins price have to be for them to be
trillionaires well I at $288,000 Bitcoin
I think that they're worth 56 billion
dollars so I did the math dude it with
if you own 1% of the network I think
it's like 4.5 million dollars for you to
have a trillion dollars yeah that's
we're probably in the same boat right I
said $288,000 Bitcoin they are worth 56
billion
so you're saying at 4 million dollar 4.5
million dollar Bitcoin they're worth a
trillion it's crazy
a trillion
a big number it's hard to even
conceptualize that's how the world works
man mom down get money get paid all
right guys listen this was a blast we
appreciate you tuning in happy having
day we'll do it again later feed the
chickens I need eggs boyo feed calm
polio-free calm block fight calm / pop
we'll show you whatever we got see you
guys